this is the longest interview i've ever
done because there are such intriguing
uh questions
well yeah the fact i'm still here it's
just but
i've had a great time i don't go to
our next next exchange
carl fristen is considered by his peers
to be
the top neuroscientist that exists
probably that
ever existed now obviously he won't say
that he'll rebuff that because he's a
humble british chap who doesn't like to
draw undue attention to himself but i
give him that accolade he has a
principle called the free energy
principle which is
infamously inscrutable but we try to
make it as simple as possible
please keep in mind that while there is
plenty of technical jargon
in this podcast it's important that you
stay with it once you're at the end
you'll probably have a better
understanding as to how to interpret
what he said at the beginning this is
one of the longest conversations if not
the longest conversation with carl
firsten that exists
and not that size matters but you can
use the duration or the length of a
podcast as a proxy
for the interviewee's interest and
that's great for me as an interviewer
because hopefully the report comes
across and
influences whether or not you can absorb
the information or influences the rate
at which you can absorb it and possibly
even the comfortableness that me and
carl have with
one another aids your understanding
perhaps the integration of this
information so that you can assemble
your own veltan shawum that is your own
theory
of everything
these podcasts are extremely difficult
to produce because they require
quite a bit of preparation and if you're
interested in supporting
conversations like this or seeing more
like this or you have other ideas as to
who i should interview and you'd like to
support this channel in some way shape
or form
then please do consider going to
patreon.com
kurtjimongo literally every dollar every
donation every patron
helps a tremendous amount not only
financially but it also helps
with encouragement it helps show me that
this is something that people are
people like and are willing to support
voluntarily
thank you to all the existing patrons
and just so you know the best way to
view this podcast in spite like i said
its inscrutable nature as to what
exactly the free energy principle is
the best way to view this podcast or
listen to it is by re-listening to it
by the end of it you'll have a better
understanding as to what carl firsten
means
when he says certain terminology and
then when you re-watch
or revisit certain parts you can look at
the timestamps revisit and hopefully
gain a better understanding for those
listening and not watching
there is also a youtube channel and for
those who are watching and not listening
there is a itunes spotify google play
we're on pretty much every platform you
can look at the description to get the
links for that
thank you so much and enjoy sir it's a
pleasure
i have been looking forward to this for
quite some time as i started researching
you
i found out that you're not only one of
the top
neuroscientists that are living but you
may be the greatest neuroscientist
to ever exist i'm just going by the
approbation from your own
colleagues as well as your h index which
is another
reflection of colleagues approving of
you and your citations which is
in the six digits if i'm not mistaken
so how about first we start off with
just how is it that you balance work
and life um very badly i i should say
that i'm certainly not
the greatest neuroscientist i think
that's more of
a reflection of the fact they invented
the h index a few years ago so
it gives me an unfair fair advantage um
the balance is is um is very poor
um so most of my life i spend
um pursue academic
uh commitments um in fact in the past
in the past year also um commitments
i've taken on in relation to the
coronavirus
outbreak in terms of modeling so um
on the other hand i love what i do so
for me life is a bit of a holiday anyway
i think many people who suffer
my family in terms of my improper work
life
balance does your family get upset that
you're constantly thinking about work
or are you distracted when you're
spending time with them because
something else is on your mind
um i think they've got used to it and i
have to say that they also have their
preoccupations and their and their sort
of uh
those um the things that they invest in
so i think they are
um as guilty as i am in in not paying
proper attention to
the uh the life side of the work life
balance
do you have a daily ritual or do you
meditate do you eat a certain type of
meal
go to sleep at a specific time wake up
at a specific time what's the structure
i i am certainly a creature of habit um
and i guess we'll come back to why that
is possibly the case i should be the
case
for most creatures um so
um no i i i don't meditate but um it's a
it's an interesting question because
my daily routine does involve
a long period of thinking in the morning
so
and it's alone um so i generally
joke and perhaps not joke that i i don't
like talking to other human beings
before
lunch before 12 o'clock so my
my day typically will start with
at least an hour if not two hours
sitting and contemplating on the problem
at hand
usually in my conservatory smoking my
pipe just drilling down
without any um aids without a computer
or without any
um pen and pencil just to boil down
the simplicity of the problem at hand
and try and see the architecture of
of the solution and then it's a question
of buckling down
to emails or then uh doing
coding or mathematical derivations or
writing something up
for the rest of the day and when i start
talking to other people
you sit without a pen and a paper and
you just think with your eyes closed
um well i actually enjoy looking at the
garden whilst thinking but i do get
distracted yeah
yeah and if you see me close my eyes
i'm often thinking deeply about what
you're saying i don't want you to think
i'm distracted or sleepy just so you
know
this it just sounds extremely british of
you to have a pipe
and do you drink tea are you sitting
with biscuits do you have a breakfast
well no um in the morning it's coffee
and then tea would be for the afternoon
without without biscuits but certainly
coffee in the morning
tea in the afternoon how do you choose
which problems to tackle because i
assume that
maybe 80 percent of the reason for your
high h index is
the problem selection yeah absolutely
um and you know i often
um have heard it said that the the mark
of a great scientist
is not the the the answers that they
offer it's really the questions that
they ask and i have to say that um
most the questions that i'm obliged to
contend with
are those that are proffered um either
by colleagues internationally
and most of the time by the uh by the
younger people
um that i work with or supervise so it's
really i spend most my time in response
mode
just trying to formulate and resolve
questions that uh my
international usually younger team uh
bring to the table
so ninety percent of my work is just
basically
um helping other people solve problems
um
[Music]
about 10 of it when i have time it's
sort of focusing on you know
on my um particular hobby which um
in latter years has become the free
energy principle
but that's somewhat rare opportunity
most of the time you're working
on other slightly more practical
problems how has learning
mathematics new mathematics new physics
whatever it may be how's that changed
in your later years compared to younger
years um
it's um well practically an honest
answer to that question
um is it's much easier now um
because of things like wikipedia and the
electronic age
i mean certainly i
i had the conviction uh which i think is
a proper conviction that to make
um any real formal difference you you
had to be
able to articulate things mathematically
so you made a particular point
of um choosing an early career an
education
that covered physics and maths and
probability theory and the like
but probably not not dissimilar to your
early career um
structure um and then forgot it all
until i
um returned um after a studying as a
doctor with a psychiatrist
to uh maths via data analysis in
imaging neuroscience um so
it was extremely useful having had that
early physics
um sort of degree level education
although i'd forgotten everything i at
least had the confidence to relearn
those bits that you need to know
to make something work so it was very
much on one of the situations of sort of
c121 teach one where very quickly you
need to solve a problem
and then you went to um you know in
latter days at least you went to
wikipedia
you got the right equations and you put
them together implemented it in code
and then proceed you know on to the next
problem
so um you know i have possibly
an undue respect or reverence for
the utility of maths not you know not
just in
relation to its unreasonable efficacy
but also as a language for communication
as a you know a calculus that every
like-minded
academic um or indeed industrial partner
um will at some point subscribe to and
drill down on and understand so
i think it is the ultimate language um
uh
which you know effectively
most of what i say in words or write
textually um inherits from
and is always guided by the underlying
the underlying mathematics
before we get to the free energy
principle which i'm going to ask you to
explain as simply as you can
and then you can go as complex as you
can later but
before we get to that i found that there
were a few
words that you use in the different
interviews that i've seen of you
that i'm unsure as to what you mean
precisely when you say them so
deflationary is one
uh-huh what do you mean when you say
deflationary because i'm sure that will
come up over and over here right yes
you're right that's one of my favorite
words at the moment um
uh just taking uh if you want an honest
answer i use it in the sense of
just taking the hot air out of something
um
so um in some instances
one sees um what
an over-interpretation of certain things
so
there is always a simpler explanation
for
various phenomena or behaviors or
constructs
um so for me a deflationary
explanation is is a better thing in the
sense that it provides
a simpler more parsimonious account of
something
than was on offer before that simpler
account
came along so um
philosophically um i think i'm using it
in the sense of
what my friend andy clark who's one of
the
world's more accomplished um
philosophers refers to
as a sort of queenian desert landscape
so this inherits from
quine who um you know
conceived of a set of explanations that
was
so simple there was nothing left hence
the desert landscape
and a lot of a lot of the aspirations
of our theorizing um actually points in
that direction
a little bit like natural selection i
mean the natural selection is such a
wonderful idea probably the you know the
greatest biological
idea um certainly in the past few
centuries
and yet it is inherently tautological um
you know it just
almost goes away when you think about
the the
essential tautology of natural selection
and
so for me that's a beautiful idea that
is deflationary it explains so much
with hardly anything when you mean when
you're saying that natural selection is
tautological do you mean to say that
survival of the fittest well you're
defining fitness by survival anyway
that's exactly right yep that's exactly
what i mean yeah
okay okay now self-evidencing
self-evidencing is a philosophical term
um which i think has been around for
some time
but i was introduced to it by my other
philosophy friend
yucca powy who's currently in melbourne
as a nice perspective on
the one take on what we do or what the
imperatives existential imperatives
um behind our behavior and our
dynamics if you're a physicist which is
to maximize the
evidence for your models of of the world
so in maximizing the evidence sometimes
described perhaps poetically as
acting to garner evidence for your own
existence
you can be said to be self-evidencing um
i just say
it's a slight play on words from the
point of view of
a mathematician because um
nearly every interesting formulation um
of self-organizing systems has itself in
so you start off with self-organizing
systems
um of the sort you might see as a
computational chemistry through
self-assembly um sometimes in the
biological uh sciences people refer to
um autophagus which you know is again
greek for
for self-creation um you start off just
thinking about the information
theory that would underwrite that kind
of self-organization the first thing you
come across is self-information
um you know following that through
and you can sort of spin off um
all sorts of other selfs in terms of um
self-serving behaviors that you can
write down in terms of information
theory
and for me the simplest and most um
the prettiest is this notion of
self-evidencing what about equilibrium
state versus a non-equilibrium steady
state
so that one's not idiosyncratic to you
right no
no heavens though um and again remember
i'm
i'm a bit of an amateur physicist um
you're i
trained as a physicist as a young man
but haven't um haven't
sort of um really been in that field
throughout my career but
my reading of um physics um
as it applies to um the kinds of systems
that we we have to deal with
um can be read as sort of 20 century
physics
where you're dealing with closed systems
at
equilibrium and then the 21st century
people got much more interested
in the physics of open systems that are
far from equilibrium or non-equilibrium
and what can you do with these kinds of
systems well you can
you can write down their dynamics their
density dynamics you can
formalize the behavior of the
probability distribution over the
various states of these systems
and how they would unfold from any given
initial condition to some steady state
distribution
um for me though it is the steady state
distribution which is interesting
because that provides you with a
well-defined
probability distribution and once you've
got that
then you can go forward in terms of the
information theory
and spin off everything that you might
want to in terms of inference and
and the like so the non-equilibrium part
is absolutely crucial in the sense that
it defines
a set of questions about systems
that um are in exchange
with a world out there so that there is
you know from the
uh thermodynamic point of view an
exchange of energy and entropy
between the system and of itself and the
rest of the universe
um from a mathematical point of view um
the non-equilibrium aspect is
is inherited from um the prevalence
of um circular flows
solenoidal flows the sort of flow which
if you were in machine learning would
destroy detailed balance and
that would have a lot of technical
implications but what i'm talking about
is
is um sort of the fluctuations that you
get
um in classical mechanics like the
orbits of heavenly bodies or the um
the circular fluctuations you get in
predator prey relationships or
red queen dynamics wherever you look at
sort of interesting systems
that persevere over time you see this
sort of
solidal circular um oscillatory-like
behavior
and it is that which characterizes real
dynamical systems that are
you know i repeat not isolated from the
rest of the universe or
are not carefully and shrouded in a heat
buff
like an idealized gas but they actually
have to contend
with an exchange with the outside world
so that's what's encapsulated by a
non-equilibrium
system um the steady state means that
if you leave it alone for long enough it
will self-organize
into some recognizable configuration
that you can describe probabilistically
probabilistically with a probability
density
function uh or in terms of some
attracting set a pullback attractor
whatever your preferred kind of calculus
our maths would be
so steady state refers to it over time
being somewhat stable but then the
non-equilibrium means that it can ramify
it can go between here and then it may
jump here and then it may jump here but
between three only instead of one would
be equilibrium no i think that's a very
nice description um
so yes absolutely so the steady state um
just means that
you know the system has settled down um
to some um attracting set of states
but within those that set of states
there is exactly what you were
you were referring to there's an
itinerancy there are different sort of
you know regimes or sub-manifolds of an
attracting set
which gives it an itinerancy or a
wandering so it moves around
from one part of the attracting set to
another part of the attracting set
so the example i like to use when trying
to
get this notion in play is
you know at every level of
self-organization
in me you see this phenomena whether
it's very very fast fluctuations
in electrophysiological potentials in
one
part of my dendrite of one cell in
one part of my brain you're fluctuating
at say the gamma frequency
or whether it's my heartbeat you know
unfolding during the cardiac cycle
or whether it's me getting up in the
morning having a cup of coffee
doing my emails or whether it's the
annual
cycles that we all enjoy sort of
christmas easter summer holidays
every one of these instances of
um you know an open system at some kind
of
non-equilibrium steady state has in
common the fact you keep revisiting
certain states of being and it's that
revisiting
that defines this attracting set and
um the your the steady state aspect so
exactly as you are doing with your
fingers you are
you are moving around from sort of uh
one part of the manifold to another part
of the manifold
you know if you're a physicist who did
dynamical systems theory you might think
of this in like a um
a heteroclinic cycle where you're moving
from one unstable point to the next
unstable point
but you're always ultimately coming back
to the same attracting set
of unstable points so it's it's that you
know
um non-equilibrium so we're not at a
fixed point we're not all aspiring
um you know to be at thermodynamic
equilibrium
um there's an itinerancy and a
complexity and a richness
to the behavior but on the other hand
it's a behavior that evinces the same
kinds of states
the neighborhood of places in state
space time and time and time again
for the duration of the existence of of
that particular system or particle or
person in question
why did you call it the free energy
principle when i first heard
well i heard about it quite a few times
then i kept dismissing it because i
thought it was
referring to perpetual motion or the
extraction of
energy from vacuum
you're fluctuations right i understand
that it has something to do with free
energy in the physics term but what led
you to
calling it the free energy principle and
have you had have you heard of other
people
have you heard of the case of mistaken
identity from other people this is just
me
no no i i've certainly come across that
but not so nicely articulated or gently
articulated
um so yeah for me in my world
the free energy was the um the most
natural and obvious
uh thing um to call it because um
the the kind of free energy that we're
dealing with or when i say we
um people in either base in statistics
or
laterally what would be known as as
machine learning
would would would always refer to this
quantity this variational free energy
as a computable objective function for
any
inference or estimation problem so
whether you're doing sort of
um classification with machine learning
and you're using restricted builds of a
machine and you're using
or let's make it more current so you're
doing um
you using high-end deep learning using a
variational auto encoder
to try and recognize um some sequence of
images
then the weights that you are
optimizing within that deep learning
setting in that particular variation
auto encoder setting
um are optimized with respect to a
variation free energy
so this variation free energy um plays a
central role and has done for
for um more than half a century now
in optimization problems um
its origins are actually really really
quite interesting
um historically again this is not really
my field but from what i gather
there are two ways that the free energy
sort of
came into play the the the american
route
and this starts with richard feynman as
as with most things
um so he had the problem of basically
um wanting to
[Music]
you know express simply
um evaluate the probability distribution
over all the paths a an electron say
could
could
could take and he realized that that was
a
you know an intractable um integration
problem he could he couldn't work out
the sort of
the normalization constant to make sure
that probability distribution
summed to one so he was faced with an
intractable
um effectively integration problem in
quantum electrodynamics
so he solved him by converting that
integration problem into an optimization
problem
and the way he did it was to introduce a
variational free energy
that was always greater than the
quantity that he wanted to minimize or
was less than
the quantity that he wanted to maximize
which in this instance is just
the marginal likelihood or the
likelihood distribution of various paths
say a small particle might take um so
that's where i learned about free energy
um essentially a feminine feminist free
energy
that was provided a bound approximation
to something that you actually wanted to
maximize or optimize
um and in my world
that that thing you want to maximize
is the model evidence or the marginal
likelihood
because back to self-evidencing but also
the marginal likelihood
sort of indicating that this is a
central notion in in physics
in bayesian statistics as well
and that quantity that variation free
energy um has been in play now for
for for you know not quite a century but
certainly many many decades
um currently known as an elbow elbow
an evidence lower bound so that evidence
lower bound
underwrites you know all of high-end
machine learning
um and you know certain simply
reduced cases of it i i would i would
actually suggest probably
all of machine learning at some point
refer to
or can be seen as a special case of this
the other route um inherits more from
the russian side
and this is the notions of algorithmic
complexity underlying universal
computation
via common growth complexity and sort of
induction
um so the big drive there
is is again formulating
universal computation as basically
communicating or articulating or
encoding
some structure in the simplest way
possible
by introducing a bound
on the thing that you want to you want
to optimize or minimize or extremize
so you can also find the free energy
in the context of um sort of
um a more shallow nest
like uh take on on communication and
optimization
and david mckay sort of originally
um brought that perspective to the table
perspective
that was was um well understood
by people like uh wallace in uh
melbourne
who themselves had taken it from from
the
the russian literature and so on offer i
think he was
he was an american but also uh you know
taking this algorithmic complexity
so it's a very long answer to to
actually say that the free energy
principle
or the principle of minimizing free
energy
uh has underwritten um universal
computation
uh practical approaches to quantum
electrodynamics
and machine learning since since the
1950s
so it was you know that's what the free
energy means it's not the
the energy is costless it's it's it's
just uh
borrows from the formalism of the
thermodynamic
uh free energy either gibbs or helmholtz
free energy
okay this sounds like a great time to
explain what the free energy principle
is i know you touched on it but
for the people who aren't aware
right um so there are
when asked to do this i i'll give you
i'll give you a choice
you can either take the high road or the
low road
so the high road
would start with a consideration of what
it is
to exist to be something and
then unpack that in terms of um
physics um and then ultimately you get
to a picture of things that exist
as things that look as if they are
trying to minimize
their free energy and you can interpret
that in terms of action and perception
sentient behavior effectively a physics
of sentience
um where everything entailed by
a particle that could be a sort of small
particle or it could be a person
or a plant anything that exists can be
seen as or understood or characterized
as trying to optimize or minimize
a free energy through changes in
internal states or through
action upon the world that would be the
high road and we can take that if you
choose that option
the low road would be sort of building
up
um a sense of there being just one
imperative
um from the the notions that
probably um can be found in the students
of plato
throughout philosophy through canned
through helmholtz
through modern day psychology and
subsequently machine learning
um would appeal to a story
a narrative about prediction and
inference and that we are
all effectively prediction machines
um where in this setting the
the existential imperative is basically
to reduce
prediction error so by particular i
simply mean that
we have in mind
a model of the way that the world works
and that
we can leverage that model to produce
predictions about
the sensory evidence at hand and the
disparity or the difference between
our predictions and our actual sensory
samples can be called prediction error
and it turns out mathematically that the
sort of the high road and the low road
um converge because the prediction error
is just the gradient of the free energy
that you're trying to
try to minimize so i'll come back to you
which would you prefer the
the high road or the low road okay first
when you say sentient do you mean the
capacity to feel pleasure or pain
or how are you using that word yeah just
a sense um just to
um not not so much the affect aspect not
the sort of the pleasure and the pain
just being able to um to represent and
infer so to have in mind um
a notion of what caused your sensations
so you know i'm using it in a
deflationary way
um so some systems um
um may or may not have the kind of
sentience
that that you'd associate with with say
a person
or a you know a pet um
say you know does a plant is a plant
sentient
um let me ask you do you think a plant
is sentient does it
does it have can it in an elemental way
feel its way around the world or have
some internal representation
of um of the world that is that it
inhabits
i would say it's a scary thought to
think of plants as extremely sentient
because you crush them
constantly and even if you're a
vegetarian so i'm unsure if i think that
they can feel pleasure pain it does seem
like it's
clear that they respond to the
environment and that they take in
sensory information
and act on it yes yeah i think that's
absolutely true
in fact interestingly they they have the
same sort of
um electrochemical message passing that
we have with our axons
you know in the brain it unfolds at a
much slower time scale
but the you know the physics of the
message passing the internal
um the internal states of a plan to
actually uh
comply with very similar kinds of
computational architectures that
your bread and mind is i i would say a
plant is sentient but
not to the extent that it has no
emotions or even a sense of self you
know there are lots of
graded um very you know sort of
ladder there are lots of steps on the
ladder of sentience right through to
self-awareness and pleasure and pain
um but i'm talking about a very
elemental sort where
there's something going on in the inside
that
is caused by and causes stuff that's
going on on the outside
um that you can read as a kind of
representation
or an inference um about the causes of
sensations
okay so when you ask this question as to
which explanation would i prefer the
high road or the low road
i imagine that as top down versus bottom
up
and when i say that please let me know
if i'm understanding it correctly when
you say the bottom up it's something
like looking at what exists and seeing
that it does
act such that it minimizes some quantity
or it wants to minimize
error in some way versus the top down
which looks like
if i was to sit in an armchair with my
eyes closed and think
what exists okay what would have to be
the case if it were to exist what
properties would it have to have
so one is is that correct am i no that's
am i obtuse
no that's brilliant yeah okay
let's start with the top down let's just
do the top down because i we have quite
a few questions so let's start from the
arm chair
excuse me so okay i'll do the top down
with a little nod to the bottom up so we
don't we don't miss out on anything so
you've just said what you know um uh
basically the strategy
you start off okay i want to explain um
anything a theory of everything yep so
what's a thing
well the first thing you have to contend
with well how do i differentiate a thing
from
no thing or nothing or something else so
that immediately
implies that you're splitting or carving
or partitioning
the states of some universe into
states that belong to the thing and
states that don't belong to the thing
and when you think about what that means
you have to
um well you're compelled then
to consider the statistical
dependencies that demarcate
something from nothing and
when one drills down on that um you come
across this notion
of a markov boundary or markov blanket
which is effectively
a set of states that separate or
insulate
internal states on the inside from
external states on the outside
so you have this picture of transactions
mediated
by standard dynamics by of the sort
you'd see
in physics with a launch van formulation
um the kinds of equations of motions
that everybody uses
to you know to to to build their
favorite physics whether it's sort of
quantum mechanics or classical mechanics
uh
um cisco mechanics they all start with
with the notion
of there being some dynamics out there
and the special kind of dynamics that
you that we're interested in
in terms of talking about anything um
is um applies
to systems that have this partition
so as soon as you put this partition
into play
which is basically a partition where
internal states
influence external states this direction
through the blanket states
and then external states influence
internal states in the other direction
and vicariously through the markov
blanket you have this notion of some
generalized
action and perception that you know the
inside influences the outside so somehow
the thing is acting upon the world but
at the same time
through the blanket states the outside
is acting upon the inside
you know and we normally divide the
blanket states into
sensory and active states so in this
instance the outside external states it
impress themselves upon the sensory
states and then the sensory states
influence the internal states and so
there's a sort of
circular causality implied
by this partition now all you do then
is say well look let's just look at the
long-term behavior
of any system um that
would that you can
describe in terms of the the dynamics or
the rate of change
of the probability distribution over
states or density of the states
and note that
because we are interested in systems
that have attained a non-equilibrium
steady state
that probability density is not itself
changing
and when one does that when one looks at
the solution
to the density dynamics in the context
of the markov blanket
you get a particular kind of mechanics
and that mechanics is exactly the same
as
quantum mechanics or statistical
mechanics
but with one key difference now it
applies
in the setting of a markov blanket and
it that that's where the
interpretation of um things
as self-evidencing comes from because
you can always
write down the flows that maintain
this steady state as um
effectively trying to trying to minimize
their prediction error
or minimize their self-information or
minimize their their
what's known as surprisal information
theory which
which mathematically is just the same
thing as uh
what statisticians like to call bayesian
model evidence or the log
of the probability of these sensory
states given my implicit
model encoded by
the internal states so what you end up
with
is a description of anything
defined stipulatively in terms of a
possessing a markov blanket
defined by its non-equilibrium steady
state density
whose dynamics or flows must have this
property
that the internal states and the
the active part of the blanket states
must be performing a gradient flow
on this self-information and then
you make a further move and say well
this self-information
can be written down as a free energy
functional well the free energy
if i interpret the internal states
as encoding bayesian beliefs or
probabilistic beliefs
about the external states so now you
have a mathematical image or a picture
of existential dynamics
that inherit from having a markov
blanket where you can say
that the dynamics of the internal states
look as if
they're trying to maximize their model
evidence or trying to minimize
uh their free energy or prediction error
and that's basically the story
so a story that rests really upon what
physicists will understand as dynamics
and
average flow at non-equilibrium steady
state
and in particular the gradient flows
so perhaps it would demystify this to
say that
and coming back to helmholtz it was a
key architecture these ideas on the
low road to describing um
so um what you're what
among the many things that helmholtz
brought to the table was you can always
decompose
the flow for example let's take the flow
of a fluid
into two parts there's one that's
flowing up or down
gradients say concentration gradients
and there's another
circular flow which flows around the iso
probability contours or the iso gradient
uh the
the iso contours of of any uh of any
function
so what we're talking about is the
gradient flow part of it
not the solenoidal which is the other
circular part of the flow that
we were previously talking about in
terms of um
defining non-equilibrium as opposed to
equilibrium systems
and you know that gradient flow then
can be now read as a gradient flow
on a variational free energy um
which is wonderful from the point of
view of people like me in neuroscience
because
now what you've got is a description of
neurodynamics
so you've got now a first principle
account
of how neuronal activity or states
change as a function of their state over
time and
you can write that down now as a
gradient flow on this one
quantity this variation free energy that
endows that gradient flow there's
that dynamics um with an interpretation
that they're trying to maximize
the evidence for their model internally
of what's going on on the outside
okay let's zoom out and we see in your
model most of the time when you're
presenting with the powerpoint slides i
see nodes and then they have arrows
and so the nodes are connected with
different arrows and then that's what
affords a markov blanket
i have a couple questions the arrows
represent influence
which to me is a synonym for causation
so i'm wondering is causation necessary
for
this model because some people argue
that causation is an illusion
so for example sean carroll may say that
and
i'm well first of all let's tackle that
does your model presuppose causation
um yeah in a deflationary sense yes
um so inflationary yes so
in in the sense uh you know
i i i'm not quite sure what sean has
said but i will i want to agree with it
with what what
whatever you said um so this is a very
trivial causation that
that is implicit when you write down any
random differential equation or
stochastic differential equation or
longevity expression
if you just write down a universe
in which there are states that change
with time
as a function of those states plus say
some random fluctuations to make it a
random
or a stochastic differential equation
then what you are saying
is that the flow of
those states the rate of change of those
states is caused by those states
that's the only causality that is in
play here
so it's its causality of a rather sort
of um
elemental and trivial sort that that i
have to refer to also i normally but
people often refer to as um uh causality
in a controlled theoretic sense that the
system
is causal in the sense that there is
just motion or dynamics that is caused
by
by a state so the causality here is
inherits just from writing down
differential equations
that interestingly are only expressed in
motion over time so there's a deep link
betw
behind this trivial causality and time
uh because you're just writing down a
differential equation
after that there's no causality there's
nothing else after that
um the the sort of the causal inference
that the
the sort of um that
um would be of the kind uh say that
people like pearl in his causal
mechanics talk about
um i think that's much more um a
product of inference but you'd have to
actually work right up through the free
energy principle with you know
you know to actually understand what it
means just to
measure things you know let alone have
ideas about
do did this a cause be you know you
first of all got to even
uh you know um work out how would you
measure how you infer the existence of
a out there and b out there so you know
the free energy principle starts at a
very very low level and then
the baby steps works up to higher order
notions of things like causality
does that answer your question about the
the other
yeah does time always have to be the
parameter or can it be something else
because then it presupposes time as well
yeah
um yeah i mean in my um in
in our work yeah it is always time
because you can generalize that you know
just treat time as another another
another coordinate if if you wanted to i
i
i personally haven't found that a very
useful move i all have an enormous
respect for people who can think
like that uh you know and completely
generalize
uh this um you know get all um you know
gauge theoretic um sort of um
understandings of the underlying
geometry for me i have to say
you know i just start with a random
differential equation and then
everything else falls from that
um and in particular you know you you
you keep connected
to um
useful things of the sort that do rest
upon dynamics
um you know if you if you so don't keep
if you don't treat time as a special if
you like coordinate
or um aspect of some
of some space um then
you know um it it's
less easy in a straightforward way to
connect to things like entropy
production
or um even things like sort of
information entropy
information then in dynamical systems
so i personally do you know
time starts off with a privileged um
position in the formulation in the sense
that it underwrites
the meaning of a differential equation
do you see that as then meaning that the
free energy principle as it's currently
formulated
is incomplete in some manner given
special relativity let's say that or
any relativity says that time and space
must be on some equal footing and if
you're
saying that time has some privileged
position then well position needs to
have a
an equally privileged position right
yeah that question is above my pay grade
i personally don't know you can easily
um get um
dynamics or mechanics
out of a longevan formulation
that has time bait into the very core
of it you know at the beginning with
just right now the launch on you can
work the whole way thing
the whole density dynamics up um
and at non-equilibrium steady state you
can write down quite you know
a simple potential function that
describes general relativity um so i
don't think there's no i didn't know
that
okay because when i was looking at some
of your notes i know you call it the
launch van
equation i can never pronounce that so i
always called it the kalman
forward equation for some reason that's
easier for me but whatever
the launch man is that correct launch
fan yeah so that's how i say it anyway
yes
okay well let's just say like that for
now
yes right okay so the launch van
equation
it can it can imply newtonian mechanics
i saw that you were showing that in one
of your slides as well as quantum
mechanics
as well as some aspect of thermodynamics
and then i forgot the fourth one but
then i didn't see special relativity or
non-relativistic quantum mechanics
you're saying that you can tweak some of
the parameters to derive
general relativity yep um and it all
rests upon the way that you configure
the um
the um the the gradient flows that
have the dissipative um the lender
system and dissipative aspect
um versus the um solenoidal flows the
that characterize more conservative
systems so
when we're talking about special sorry
general relativity for example
excuse me um we're almost um
considering the limiting case where the
random fluctuations are attenuated by
being averaged away
we're talking about sort of massive
bodies um moving around so
it's just a question of of looking at
the various functional forms
you would get out of the solution to the
common growth forward equation
under the limit that gamma is is is um
is very very sorry
the amplitude the random fluctuations is
very very small so the gradient flows
almost disappear um so then it's just a
question look at the functional forms
and with a few nonlinearities here and
there you can you can quite you can
quite you can quite easily
uh write down something that that the uh
general you know relativity we will be
quite comfortable with
there are some interesting twists here
but you know if you start putting back
the random fluctuations into the so
general
solution um to um
the um the focal point equation or the
uh
the kamalgr forward equation um and
sorry just for the people listening the
focker planck equation and then the
launch van equation and the kolmogorov
forward equation are all synonyms
yes or the special cases of one another
yeah well
the launchvan equation is is just the
the underlying
uh equation that describes the the
the flow of the system as a function of
the states
but if you if you know that and you know
the amplitude of any random fluctuations
on that flow
then you can do you can equivalently
write that down
as a focal planck equation or a whole
molecular forward equation
i should also say incidentally you can
also write it down
equivalently in terms of a path integral
formulation
all of these could be um thought of as
different ways of just articulating the
same thing
um so but the density dynamics most
transparently inherits from the
you know from the uh the focal plank or
the common graph
formulation which is explicitly about
how the probabilities
over the states um evolve over time
so one example of that would be this the
time independent
scrolling a wave equation um you know
which is
you know one version of a vodka plank
equation
what they have in common is describing
the dynamics
of um of systems um
uh in terms of uh the probability
density over the states
or if you need quantum mechanics over
the other sort of the
um i would say the wave function of
states
um so at steady state
um if i really need to go to steady
state but certainly
once you've written down um the
the foca planck equation um and
solved it for uh the flow and then use
the helmholtz decomposition
to split the contributions to flow into
the solenoidal and
gradient flow parts then that provides
sort of a nice way of looking at
limiting cases so
the the gradient flow is realized by
the random fluctuations so that you know
for
for people who you are not physicists um
i often use the following analogy that
you know imagine that i placed a drop of
ink
in a cup of water um and
the ink for dissipative systems um
or your dissipative ink would disperse
itself throughout the solvent as a
random molecular uh fluctuations um
cause the ink molecules to diffuse down
concentration gradients
until you had you know a maximum entropy
dissipated
dissolved um um uh
uh sort of uh equilibrium within the
sort of the heat bath or
or the bound is supplied supplied by the
glass
that's not the kind of system that we're
interested in that's a 20th century
sort of equilibrium physics what we're
interested in is special kinds of ink
that seems to gather themselves up again
into a little globule
and that gathering up in the context of
sir
you stirring the uh stirring the the
glass of water
um can always be written down in accord
with the
helmholtz decomposition into two kinds
of flow
one kind of flow is up concentration
gradients
so it's this is the gradient flow i was
talking about so the molecules are
gathering themselves
together paradoxically if you like
looking as if they're flowing
towards each other or to the highest
concentration the highest
probabilities or log probabilities and
it's that it's that
gradient flow that is um responsible for
this self-assembly this sort of um
the uh the emergence of this attracting
set
of a small number of states that i i
keep visiting and then the solenoidal
flow
is this sort of circular flow around
um around the ice the constant you know
in this instance the concentration
um profile the i
the iso concentration lines whereas the
gradient flow is is going to the
you know the maximum concentration or
the maximum probability density
so that's non-equilibrium steady state
crucially
that gradient flow is exactly balancing
the dispersion
due to the random fluctuations so
put that another way the gradient flow
that keeps things glued together as it
were that keeps things
pointing towards that attracting set
that pullback attractor that
states that have a high non-equilibrium
state
density is exactly offsetting the
dispersive dissipative
effects of the random fluctuations which
means that the random fluctuations
realize the gradient flow
so you have to have random fluctuations
before
you can have at non-equilibrium steady
state
the gradient flow so what would happen
if you took them away well what would
happen is there will be no gradient
flows
and things would just have solenoidal
orbits and then we have
basically lagrangian mechanics we have
you know a mechanics app for describing
large bodies heavenly bodies moons and
earths and the like
all they can do is move around in
circles
so they've just got solenoidal flow
that's because there
aren't all the random fluctuations are
averaged away so they're effectively
zero so they can't realize
the gradient flows so they don't fall
towards each other
you know with you know with a suitable
potential energy
um that would define the you know
the gradient flows or the form of that
non-equilibrium
density on the other hand you could say
well no i'm
more interested in systems um that are
hot and fast
really fast like so quantum fast
where the solenoidal pit can be ignored
i'm just going to focus in on the
on the random fluctuations or the the
impact of those on the density dynamics
and then you can ignore the solenoidal
flow we return
to systems that detail balance and we
can um
um write down certain you know all
all our favorite thermodynamic laws um
you know and derive all the integral
fluctuation theorems that underwrite
generalizations
of those laws so you know from that
perspective classical mechanics where
general relativity might live for
example um
lives at one end of the spectrum very
large cold
no random fluctuations and then quantum
mechanics lives
um at the other end where it's dominated
by
random fluctuations very fast gradient
flows and in the middle
is where we live where we've got both
the
um so we're neither committed to
disorbiting for eternally
um so uh uh we're you know um
orbiting um some
uh you know some center committed
to uh a periodic orbit um
for the rest of our lives nor do we
dissipate or behave
you know in a sort of in a quantum way
but we're sort of halfway between
um we're at that that right sort of
scale where
there's lots of solenoidal there's lots
of oscillations that you know
that we we are exposed to imposed from a
larger scale such as tides
that we generate ourselves such as
oscillations in our hearts and our
physiology and our brains
um but at the same time we do have to
contend with the random fluctuations so
you know we spend a lot of our time
doing our gradient flows gathering
ourselves up
planning homeostasis keeping ourselves
in
you know actively keeping ourselves um
within certain bounds within
within that within that attracting set
and this moving up the gradient flow is
this analogous to what schrodinger
talked about when he said that life
resists entropy in some way yeah i think
that's absolutely right um
you're asking as if you didn't know
that's exactly right so you know in the
presence of these
um for
for at equilibrium uh for you know
certainly enclosed
systems um that don't have um
um sort of low entropy pullback
attractors
um then you will get the second law you
know in the usual way
where all the random fluctuations
eventually dissipate you and hence you
get dissipative systems and dissipative
dynamics and yet somehow we we
in our existence we're in existence
proof that that's a violation of that
kind of
behavior um and that's basically where
the free energy principle starts it just
says
there are things out there that have to
be explained
that seem to resist the second law so um
framed in terms of negative neg entropy
uh there's an aspiration
right uh you know to frame it in terms
of
um of resisting those that entropic
dissipation
um by this gathering up behavior and it
is those gradient flows
that are responsible when you just write
down the
the dynamics in terms of the helmholtz
decomposition
for providing that balance between the
dissipative effects of
random fluctuations and the
self-organizing
dynamics that exactly balance those
those dissipative effects to give you
this
this non-equilibrium steady state
professor when i was first researching
the free energy principle
i kept coming up to cautions
about how
intellectually formidable it is and if
one was to just go by the
just the warning signs one would think
that it was more
abstruse than particle physics or
general relativity
and i'm curious why do you think it has
this
reputation here's an example when you
search general relativity or particle
physics or quantum field theory stand or
the standard model or any grand unified
theory
i don't think i've ever read a single
sentence except
on quantum mechanics that says this is a
difficult theory to understand
however on the wikipedia page for the
free energy principle it says this is
notoriously difficult to understand
yeah um
[Music]
so i'm just trying to think of other
examples that um i'm not saying that
it's easy to understand in the least
what i'm wondering is
why do you think it has this reputation
i see yes
um well i think it's largely because
somebody slipped in that wikipedia
that sentence in wikipedia to be quite
so becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy
absolutely and it's entertaining um it's
yeah and of course it it it's um i mean
i know it's not as hard as
uh quantum physics and um and
um thermodynamics because i used to do
those and i can tell you the free energy
principle the maths is much simpler than
than quantum physics or general
relativity um it is much simpler
but it is mathematical but if you're
you're you're in dialogue with
psychologists who um don't do
mathematics then then there can be this
sort of
inflationary ratification of the ideas
and then there's a mystery
because you you don't see the simplicity
that is inherent in the
in the mathematical formulas and the
functional forms that you're dealing
with
um but i i quite like that i think it's
quite funny really
keep that in the wikipedia page okay so
the free energy principle do you see it
as being a potential
theory of everything first of all you
have to decide what are the dissiderada
of a theory of everything
but the way that i one of the reasons
i'm interested was from seeing that
slide
about the launch van equation or the
kalmac or whatever that equation
and seeing that it when you tweak the
parameters you can either generate
newtonian mechanics or general
relativity at least you're saying that
now i haven't seen that and quantum
mechanics and so on
so then that to me means it's a more
fundamental principle than those which
makes it a candidate for a theory of
everything
but then i just heard you say well
there's the quantum mechanical world
let's say high fluctuations then there's
low fluctuations of general we
live in the middle so then is the free
energy principle simply a principle of
the middle
and not the one that generates all three
or do you see it as being a theory of
everything itself
so that's a very good question um
which deserves two completely different
um answers
um i i think the thing that the free
energy principle brings to the table
um is it
is only licensed by the presence of a
markov blanket so basically
um the way i look at this is it's just
applying
box standard um
variational calculus of the kind that
people have been using for centuries
well not centuries but so in certain
schools
at the most right um um to you know
to to get at um formal
formulations of of of um
classical mechanics and quantum
mechanics and cisco mechanics or
strictly speaking stochastic mechanics
uh thermodynamics
um so you know it uses exactly the same
maths the only thing that's special
about it is that it applies that math in
the context of
a marco a markov blanket or a particular
partition
into inside and outside and separated by
blanket states
that's the only thing that it brings to
the table and in
in that sense if you allow
me to interpret everything as
every space thing then thingness as
defined stipulatively
by a markov blanket that allows you to
demarcate
a thing from not thing it is certainly a
theory of everything
by definition but in a very deflationary
way
right right now when you say
deflationary see to me the way that you
use it
is different than how you described it
unless i'm misunderstanding it the way
that i hear you using the term is
like there are concepts that we have a
colloquial understanding is to its
connotations
but you use it in such an abstract
manner that it
coincides with the colloquial only
seldomly and so
we shouldn't take it too seriously for
example when someone says surprise
it doesn't or belief it doesn't mean
that that atom has a belief that's the
way that i understand deflation am i
misunderstanding deflationary no
well well not at all no you're certainly
understanding my use of the word but
it is quite likely that i'm using the
word uh i i'm abusing the word or at
least
misusing it but that's exactly what i
meant yes
yeah and so it is it's getting under the
hood and i'm not reifying and not
associating
all the psychological interpretations so
you know i i get that a lot i have to
suddenly pause and say
when i say amazing belief i of course do
not mean something you can talk about
that you have a conviction about
these these are just conditional
probability distributions
um so know you you always have to sort
of say look we're talking about
something much simpler here
than you might think um and i think that
may in part be an explanation as why
people
think that the free energy principle is
difficult to understand it's not
it's just they think it is because
they're um
they're reading it using um folk
psychological
or uh possibly from my point of view
over rarefying verifying refining the
mathematics
i see i see when i first started
learning free energy principle when i
first started learning it
what struck me was its connection to
disparate fields so biology physics
machine learning and so on and it
reminded me of
in mathematics there's modular forms
which keep coming up over and over
and there are problems which previously
were intractable that when you recast
them in terms of modular forms they
become
easier to solve do you mind listing some
of the
applications of the free energy
principle that
let's say reformulates previously
convoluted
complex problems into something more
simple and the different fields maybe i
can even when i'm editing this maybe
i'll even list like
physics and then here's how it helps
physics here's how it helps biology
here's how it helps machine learning so
do you mind going through a couple
examples you can go through this quickly
because i'm sure you've done this many
times
and i'm mainly interested in a list well
no that's a very interesting question no
no i haven't um so but you're absolutely
right so
you know the theory of everythingness
which is
you know i use in a rather cheaty way to
interpret every
thing and its thingness which is the
theory um
is also i think claimed by
this uh the free energy principle in the
sense you're you're
you're you're hinting out that it
provides an explanatory framework
although albeit deflationary for many
different disciplines
and you see that um in terms
of it really being the underlying maths
behind all kinds of explanations for
um behavior
of a purposeful or systematic sort so
for example you can interpret the um
this this quantity either cast as a
variation free energy
or the thing that it provides an
approximation to or abound on which is
the
um the log probability of being in
attracting states
you can interpret that in many different
ways and you spin off
different kinds of approaches in the
life sciences and the physical sciences
that suddenly are seen as just different
ways of expressing the same underlying
mechanics
so a particular instance here would be
interpreting
the um the free energy as a value
function
a negative a loss function yeah so then
you can write down
reinforcement learning uh you can write
down
expected utility theory in economics you
can write down
optimal control theory in engineering so
all of these things have in common
the notion that you want to have
controlled
dynamics that optimize some loss
function but if the loss function
is is just the negative evidence or the
free energy
you've now got an explanation as to why
all of these takes on
interesting behaviors of the kind that
economists and behavioral psychologists
and control theoreticians study have to
that they're looking at they're looking
at exactly the right kind of dynamics
because
all of these systems have to possess
this fundamental property
and then you can you're not only um
if you like provide a unifying framework
that you can now start to understand
yeah well where does the bellman
optimality principle come from
well you can actually cast it as a
limiting case
of a principle of station reaction
hamilton's principle of stationary
action
when applied to a markov blanket which
is just the free energy principle so
if you wanted me to say you know in in
one sentence what is the free energy
principle
it is the application of hamilton's
principle of stationary action
to a markov blanket that's interesting
that's interesting
so yeah where do you get the bellman
optionality principle from well
if you take away lots of uncertainty
around um you know from
from the probabilistic um uh treatment
on offer from the free energy principle
you end up with about an automatic
principle
so that you know that provides a
unifying take on
things like basin decision theory when
you put the
uncertainty back in again you get
something
which is now a mixture of bayesian
decision theory and optimal bayesian
design
sometimes known as active learning in
machine learning
so now you have a principal first
principle account
of the so-called exploration
exploitation trade-off
which just dissolves in the free energy
principle you know the free energy has
two bits to it
um i won't go into the details but in
the same way that
a good statistician is always trying to
optimize the the evidence
the marginal likelihood of or the
evidence for
or the variation of free energy
associated with their model
they're just trying to provide an
accurate account
of the data at hand that is as simple or
minimally complex as possible
so we come back to algorithmic
complexity uh under the hood here
so in the same way you got this these
dual aspects to the good
inference again complying with occam's
principle
possibly even uh james's principle of
maximum entropy
applied to belief structures or um
posterior beliefs amazing beliefs you
you you've got this sort of
dual aspect
to what is a good inference which has
this sort of
accuracy on the one hand and the
complexity of on the other hand
and when you apply this in an inactive
setting when you have to
have to make moves and decisions and
consider um
not just um you know me as a sentient
organ absorbing
sensory states but i actually also act
and choose where to look
you get this dual aspect which is
basically expiration exploitation
i want to minimize surprise or
prediction errors by sampling those
things that i predict
i should sample like being warm and
happy and befriended
but at the same time there's also
another aspect which is this epistemic
aspect this
resolving uncertainty so if surprise
and specifically self-information
surprisal
if expected self-information is entropy
then expected surprise
is uncertainty so in minimizing surprise
and a minimizing
prediction error in expectation on
average under particular decisions
or choices i make i'm also compelled to
minimize my uncertainty
about the world out there generating my
sensations
so there's this epistemic part that
comes into play
which you know in the same way that the
um the accuracy
and the complexity and together to give
you
the model evidence or the free energy
these two sort of
exploration exp exploitation things just
add together
to give you the expected free energy so
that to my mind provides a
you know another example of the unifying
aspect where you can from a first
principle account
put together two seemingly completely
separate
strands of bayesian theorizing on the
one hand
bayesian decision theory which is all
about making the right decisions under
some
prize or some loss function and on the
other hand good
experimental design um that you know
could be read as a sort of preparing
approach to the scientific process or
possibly beyond
but they're just two sides of the same
coin so that's a nice unification
that i repeat dissolves um
things that i see as living in the 20th
century like the
the exploration exploitation dilemma
there is no dilemma
it's just how precise are your
preferences that drive that sort of um
that's technically what is actually a
risk so the
the complexity when you take the average
complexity
of the free energy um under some
expected outcomes before you've actually
made a move on the world
that becomes a chao divergence between
what you anticipate will happen
and what a priori you expect to happen
so that's risk in economics and in
um in engineering um sometimes as kl
what does kl stand for in the divergence
sorry
callback libra which um
so it's just a it's a particular well it
is just a relative entropy
it's just some a measure of um in fact
it's not a measure
i should it's uh a way of
quantifying the divergence between two
uh probability distributions or it's a
measure in the deflationary sense
well actually no no that's that's very
clever
but technically wrong now the reason i
caught myself was
um the kl divergence between a
and b is not the same as between b and a
so it's not a metric measure which is
why
technically that's correct right um so
everything it's not a measure but it's
like
like a measure so that's why it's called
divergence so
okay it's just a relative entropy this
is a way of of quantifying
how much you you know if you read a
bayesian belief as a state of mind
how much have you changed your mind and
the key
thing um at the heart of
if you like applications of free energy
principle to
inference and active inference and
bayesian decision theory
and the like is the the divergence
between your beliefs before
seeing some sensory evidence and
afterwards
so if you're a bayesian statistician
this would be the kl
divergence between the prior and the
posterior literally
how much you've changed your mind or
moved
your beliefs in response to assimilating
some new data am i supposed to
understand surprise as
equivalent to a mismatch between what
you predict and what actually happens
so error right that's an excellent
is it more complex than that well it's
um
if you want to get into the nitty gritty
so
surprise read as surprisal is um
a very simple concept concept it's just
a self-information it's a
the negative log probability of some
outcome
uh usually as a sensory state of of your
markov blanket
so if something is highly improbable or
if the outcome or your sensory state say
your physiological
sensed physiological state is high
unlikely given what you are
so the usual example here is a fish out
of out of water for example
that that has a lot of surprise um it
just means it's just a you know
a euphemism for for self-information
that scores
the kinds of outcomes that um
would be characteristic of this
self-organizing system
so it's just a way of writing down um or
scoring the probability of being in this
state
if you're that kind of system or um
technically if
you're um you have that
that that kind of pullback attractor
there's another kind of surprise um
which is the bayesian surprise
which um is often confused with that
which is i think closer
um to the notion that we're just talking
about which is the degree to which
something
causes me to change my mind the
information gain
um which is the complexity so
the complexity basically when you
um if you're looking at this as a
statistician you're given some data
and you had some prior beliefs about
what caused those data before you saw
the data
and then you use bayes rule to combine
the likelihood of those of those data
given your beliefs about how they're
caused with your prize
you can't be the posterior so posterior
after seeing the data this is now your
belief so you start with your prior
belief and then you have your
posterior belief and then there's a
movement
and that movement is this kl divergence
that we're talking about
that scores the amount you've changed
your mind that just
is the complexity it's the complexity
cost that you have paid
for providing a more accurate account or
an accurate account of the data
that you've explained that has moved
your beliefs from priors
to to posteriors so it is the
the cost of
changing beliefs in order
to do belief updating on bayesian belief
updating
i'm going on about that because it's
really quite interesting though because
you know
via things like landauer's principle and
the
equality that degree of movement
costs thermodynamic energy so that tells
you
that a good artifact a good person
or a good computer
from the point of view of existential
goodness as scored by
minimizing free energy or maximizing
marginal likelihood or moral evidence
is the kind of personal computer or
artifact
that when confronted with some new
information
will actually process and assimilate
that in a really thermodynamically
efficient way
so they'll do it with a very cool brain
they won't use very much electricity or
food
and very little will change and what
that basically means is
their prior beliefs were already quite
close to the posterior beliefs
so they already had a good idea of
what's going on so they were not
surprised
so and in not being surprised they're
trying to minimize that complexity cost
in in terms of
the price you have to pay for providing
an accurate account of some data
um your
you are you you are also maximizing the
efficiency of
of your belief updating so i think
that's quite a nice thing because what
it says if you're going to build
good artifacts good artificial general
intelligence
what you're looking for is a really
small
thing that can be powered with a battery
that's the one
that's the kind of thing that will do
the best kind of belief updating that's
very tailor-made
for the inference problem uh inference
problem at hand
sorry so we wandered away from your
question about what surprises but the
other
surprise is just basically the impromptu
implausibility of this happening to me
basically
when you were talking about what makes a
good computer or a good person
and you're using good in a different
manner i assume you're using it in terms
of
adaptive or or effective or accurate or
at least
not using too much energy to accomplish
its tasks
that to me sounds like almost a
restatement of occam's razor that you
want the minimal assumptions to account
for the most data
is that similar no oh no it's exactly
the same thing so
that's excellent yeah no that that's
things exactly so
you know the the the pressure to provide
a simple account
of the uh of the data is exactly getting
this
um paying the least complexity costs
possible for the ac
for the accurate or the fitting and um
and
that is exactly okam's principle and if
you don't know that that's important and
that's probably more important than the
accurate fitting
then you will end up with machine
learning
artifacts and devices and schemes that
over fit
and if they over fit they don't try to
minimize the complexity
of um the uh the explanation at hand or
you know that effectively their
inference
um then you will get um a
an inference and learning that does not
generalize
so inevitably if you allow for
overfitting
then you overfit today's data and
tomorrow's data
are very difficult to explain because
you've over explained today's data
so just practically what this manifests
as is a problem of sharp minima
and difficult to solve optimization
problems
in machine learning you get stuck
in local minima that have a very very
difficult yeah and and that's because
you you haven't you haven't flattened
the minima
by building into your objective function
this
simplifying um aspect this
complexity suppressing aspect and of
course once you
have an objective function um which
actually
entails that complexity minimizing
um imperative then the minima by
definition
the free energy minima are always
shallow
so that you've got a lot of latitude to
wander around your minima so you're not
committing to a particular sharp
explanation of over explaining the data
so
it's a really practically really
important you know observation though
i should say that when i talk about good
i just mean minimizing free energy or
maximizing evidence
so that's the only good for me
which is you know fit for purpose in
this world having a good model of this
of this particular world let me see if i
can explain
what i heard in another manner let's say
you're playing roulette what you want to
do is
you want to have a minimization of your
mismatch of prediction versus
actuality but let's say you have a good
reason to believe that 33 black
is going to be hit you don't put all
your eggs
in that one basket because you could be
wrong so you need to have some spread
it's not a direct delta function it's
not just that
and then that spread is equivalent to
entropy
is that correct because there's a
trade-off between you wanting to be
completely accurate but then leaving
one's options open yep no
that's absolutely right so that that
well you you use that wonderful phrase
leaving one's option open having that
latitude in pla
in in play is a very important aspect of
this
um expected complexity minimizing
imperative that you get from um you know
sort of uh trying to minimize
um the expected free energy for expected
following a particular choice or action
so um just in that particular instance
um
you know the if you would
if you were um acting according to um
uh expected utility maximization and you
thought
that the um the black 33 was
was the most likely outcome then you put
all your money as a delta function
on that outcome that's not what kl
control does that's not what with
sensitive control
it's not what the sort of the
exploitative part
of minimizing expected free energy does
it tries to match
your um anticipated outcomes with your
with your prior beliefs that
incorporates exactly that kind of
uncertainty
um and indeed there may be situations
where your behavior at the roulette
table
is doesn't look as if it's just about
trying to maximize the amount of money
that you will get following the bet you
may be
sometimes compelled to engage in
epistemic behaviors that resolve
uncertainty
so say that you had the hypothesis that
the
the the roulette wheel was rigged
and it was rigged in a way that depended
upon the way that people placed bets
then you might actually place a bet just
to see what would happen
in terms of the you know what the person
who's in charge of speeding the wheel
does so you know not every move is just
about
minimizing um some or realizing some
prior preferences or minimizing some
loss function
a lot of a lot of our moves are actually
to
resolve uncertainty and disclose
things that we don't know uh resolve our
uncertainty about the other
contingencies
under which we're operating so then you
can get into all sorts of interesting
um paradoxes in terms of deceit
and regret and making moves just to
reveal
what's going on out there and
particularly in transactions with
with with other people so that's another
you know just beyond the kl the
engineers perspective on kl control the
matching behavior
which is in psychology that's your you
try to match the probability
distributions
are from which you sample your choices
to the underlying payoff structure at
hand
um so that you know that would be one
way of looking at
the utility of a kl controller risk
sensitive
uh kind of control but beyond that
there's also
explicit sort of uncertainty resolving
moves you can make
such as checking which is a fair fair
gambling house and a non-fair one on
google before you actually
start you know commit to going to gamble
in this house as opposed to that house
yeah speaking of gambling have you heard
of newcomb's paradox
oh okay well look it up at some point
i'll say it here but
the paradox is imagine you go to
a circus tent and then someone says here
is a box it's clear and it has a
thousand dollars in it
that's box a then box b is sealed can't
see it
but the fortune teller inside there says
i think it's you can choose either the
sealed box or both boxes those are your
only choices
now what's in the sealed box is one
million dollars
ah i'm messing it up you'll just have to
look it up it's something
please let me spasmodically verbally
vomit here for a second as i try and get
it correct because it's
actually it's an interesting paradox and
i wanted to know what your theory had to
say about and obviously you can't answer
that in real time because
you might have to think about it but
it's something like okay you have a
sealed box you have a million dollars
a million dollars may be in it or it's
not i'm trying to work through what the
actual paradox is the fortune teller
says i have predicted
i'm 100 correct maybe there's a sensor
you can say there's a sensor that
analyzed your brain
and it knows what you're going to do and
she either put one million dollars in it
or didn't depending on if you
depending on if you choose ah right she
says
if you're going to choose this single
box just the box alone the sealed box
then i've included a million dollars in
it i've already predicted which one
you're going to do by the way but i'm
just letting you know
if you just picked the sealed box you
get a million dollars i put a million
dollars in it
if you choose both boxes because you're
greedy i put nothing inside the sealed
box
so then the question is what do you do
now you have to make many assumptions
you have to assume she's telling the
truth when she says that she's able to
predict you
with 100 accuracy but even if it's 99
accuracy
the paradox still holds the question is
well what do you do
you may say okay now that i'm there she
made that decision beforehand the
million dollars is either there or not i
might
may as well take both boxes so that's
one
way of reasoning through this problem
but another one is to think okay
all the people that just selected the
sealed box get one million because
that's the way that
she said it's worked she said also that
hey i've done this millions of times and
i've always predicted correctly
so then what do you do do you risk
taking both boxes or do you just take
one
and it's it shows a difference in
i forget what it's called either causal
decision theory and
there's another type of decision theory
one where you maximize
evidential based decision theory so
usually those two
imply the same solution but here they
don't
anyway i wanted to know what the free
energy principle says
one should do because it's a famous
paradox
let's forget about that then we're gonna
have to go and google that one
it sounds even more complicated than the
monty hall
uh um paradox problem um
so i know it sounds intriguing so you
you yeah
and so the paradox is is basically
um the paradox that is confronted by you
in the situation as opposed to a
paradoxical behavior that people
actually right right you want to
maximize the amount of money
so let's assume you're instrumentally
rational that is you want to maximize
your
your pleasure whatever it is what do you
do okay so forget about that something i
was wondering about the free energy
principle is how much of it do you
see as a principle like a law like a law
of physics
versus a compression mechanism so for
example what i mean by that is when you
look at maxwell's original paper for his
four
laws there are actually 26 different
equations or 24. it's two pages long
because he didn't
compress it down to the four that we now
use so these four
aren't actually four equations they're
just code
and then i i always wondered how much of
our
lagrangians are sorry the minimization
of action is an actual
principle of nature versus this
compression mechanism that says here are
your complicated equations of motion
what you can do
is you can package it into this
simplified little lagrangian that you
then
put into the euler lagrange equations
and you crank out the equations of
motions
so it's not actually
a principle in and of itself it's more
like a zipping of something that's
convoluted
so do you see the free energy principle
as
a law or do you see it as akin to what i
made an analogy about with lagrangian
mechanics and the lagrangian
that is it's just compressing it could
just be compressing yeah
um i think that um
i see it as a law um but i think that
distinction is is
very nicely articulated and i think it's
really in play in my world
in a slightly different way so um i
repeat the
the free energy principle is just
um a variational principle of stationary
action
um cast in terms of density dynamics
of things that have markov blankets
and by implication at steady state so
it is as it plays a role um
exactly the same role as hamilton's
principles of um
stationary or at least action so it
either applies or it doesn't so it's not
a
it's not a theory um um
and you're in many senses it's not very
useful you know it's just
a way of writing down and zipping things
up as you nicely put it
um in an internally coherent way that
speaks to sort of you know as all
i think these useful principles do some
symmetry or some invariance property
uh for me um the variational principles
of station reaction are the are the
simplest and most graceful way of
expressing these symmetries uh you can
do it with gage theories or
um i'm sure there are other formulations
but for me um
you know the the best way is just to to
use that
principle at least of of least action or
stationary action
um so that's what the free energy
principle does but as you say
um you know for the free energy
principle
um what does that actually mean in
practice well it means that um
anything that exists can be understood
um and simulated um or built
um as a gradient flow on a free energy
function a function of what
well the free energy is a function of
the
states the data the states of the markov
blanket
and the um
bayesian beliefs about the posterior
beliefs
about the causes of those data that are
encoded by the internal states
so um where does that um
where does the where do those beliefs
come from
um well they're defined or the free
energy is defined
uh if you think of this sort of
prediction error version or
um reading of free energy they are
defined by a genetic model
that predicts the sensations that you
would get if that model was right
so you have to have a genetic model so
you know there is going to be a universe
of genetic models you could plug
into the uh underlying um
uh gradient flows the helmholtz
decomposition that we talked about that
um that basically describes all dynamics
you know
uh for systems that can be cast valve
with markov blankets
um so the question is not so much now
the free energy principle or the
application of a variation principle at
least action
but really what is the generative model
so at this point i think then you move
away from the principle
and you start now to get into the world
of process theories and
hypotheses so and you can ask that
question or you can have those
hypotheses at a number of different
levels
you can actually take a working system a
person say if you're a psychiatrist
you know somebody who might have
obsession compulsive disorder
and you may say well i want to
understand them now
as making decisions under some model
of their lived world some genetic model
i know
their neural dynamics and i and i know
the principles that underwrite their
choices
but what i don't know is their journey
to modern their private leads so i'm
going to now reverse engineer
on the basis of their behavior what are
their prior beliefs
what what do they actually believe is
going on to ex
best explain this behavior so that would
be one application
another application might be uh building
artificial intelligence machine
artifacts
you know where i now write down
the um the prior preferences
of a generative model the kinds of
states that i want this system
uh to aspire to and i then just let it
you know i just
um equip it with active states and
actuators
and sensory states and sensors and make
a little robot
and off it will go and it will go and
epistemically forage always with a mind
to
learning about its world but also under
the constraint of its prior preferences
like keeping its battery charged
so that would be another instance but in
both applications
i've had to either reverse engineer
or commit to a particular generative
model and that's where i think the
you know you moved a long way away from
principles
and if it's a question about does this
person with obsessional compulsive
disorder
have this kind of genetic model of that
kind of narrative model
and that's now a hypothesis naturally
falsified with respect to the evidence
um if it's a question of building an
artifact
do i use a discrete state space um
generative model or a continuous one
which means i'm now committing to
different kinds of message passing
um is discrete it could be a variational
message passing or belief propagation
if it's continuous i'll be using things
like um
linear quadratic control or kalman busy
filters
um so again you're you're you're now um
in the mechanics of the processes that
are that are
realizing these gradient flows and of
course there are no principles or rules
that tell you you're right or wrong
these are all um process theories that
you know
that might work and that might not work
so you know
i think the zipping that you talked
about is from my point of view it's
basically
um uh unzipping the principle
to to to realize that under the hood
it is the generative model that supplies
the free energy gradients
that drive the gradient flows that's the
big
open question and getting the generator
model right
is in most instances scientifically or
indeed in industry
and possibly even in medical
translational practice
translation of these ideas in medical
practice
it's all about getting the right kind of
genetic model and your hypotheses
about that general about that genitive
model
you said a couple of statements that
reminded me of jordan peterson
now i'm not sure how much you follow
jordan peterson at all but he's a
proponent of
watching what someone does to infer
their beliefs so that is
okay well you're not good so you
understand what that means and then
number two
he also mentions order and chaos and the
balance between them which is
taoist that you don't want the
elimination of one or the predominance
of another you want a special balance
between them which reminds me of what
you said about surprise and then
i believe it's kale divergence right
okay you don't want one to dominate
there's a delicate balance have you
heard jordan peterson speak on order and
chaos and do you see any correspondence
between
the free energy principle and what he
says about
chaos and order yes i i think so um
i mean i would um
i would put this i mean there are a
number of different routes one could
take to that kind of issue
um you could ask yourself um
is there any um first principal account
for example of self-organized
criticality
um so you do you remember the edge of
chaos
notions from um from the
stu kaufman and self-organized
criticality that was the
the self i was trying to remember before
but that's another
one of these branches of um of physics
um which starts off with self so soc
self-organized criticality
so this is a notion um that
it is um inevitably the case that any
self-organizing system will organize
itself to a regime of critical slowing
um and dynamical instability
which you know stuart kaufman might
might have articulated in terms of
systems moving themselves towards the
edge of chaos so
towards um separate seas towards sort of
bifurcation
into regimes usually associated with
multi-stability or meta stability um um
you know depending on the nature of the
dynamical system but this
tendency to um to
do to put yourself
um in a state where
you have a repertoire of
dynamics available to you simply because
you are near disorder you're near chaos
so but you never actually go chaotic but
you just
increase the latitude of of of um
or the repertoire um of of things
you know um of dynamics that you you
that might happen to you
and that from that perspective um
then there are sort of there are i think
a number of interesting
um things that the free energy
formulation
um brings to the table the first we've
actually already touched on which was
this
building in to an optimization
perspective shallow minima to
preclude the existence of sharp minima
and just by having effectively
occam's principle baked into your
understanding
of uh um life
uh or indeed any kind of
self-organization um
as you know um trying to
optimize this bound on evidence um
or marginal likelihood then you're
necessarily saying that you want to have
these
low curvature minima you want to occupy
low curvature minima
that if you if you now ask what would
that look like in terms of
um you know coupling between internal
and external states in the context
that the the gradient flows are informed
when when out free energy minima um
by very shallow gradients what do you
get well you get exactly the sort of
um this latitude um
for excursions which have a long
correlation length
so you get this you know the kind of
critical slowing
that is associated with self-organized
criticality so
often so heavy-tailed distributions in
terms of um
in terms of um uh sort of um
sort of covariance functions for example
so that i think there's a simple and
mathematically
and deflationary account of
um the balance between
order and um
chaos at least from a purely dynamical
perspective that is on offer
via the um the minimization of free
energy with gradient flows
simply because you are dealing with
minima
that don't trap you they allow for that
latitude
so that you avoid i see i see a
particular solution
how sharp would be too much order
absolutely yeah so you just get locked
in you get you literally get stuck in a
rut you get
locked into this particular explanation
and any slight movement away from a very
sharp
minima incurs an enormous penalty um
right and you just don't make that move
but if you've got a very shallow basin
of attraction if you like
um and i repeat i think the beautiful
thing about the sort of
the free energy functionals or this free
energy functional
is that it's built to be shallow
perhaps an analogy would help here that
but um
if you think of a free energy landscape
that is parroted by
a mountain landscape right from the high
the mountains mountains and the scottish
highlands right down to the estuaries
at sea level then what you typically
tend to get
is that very high um terrains of any
landscape
have lots of high frequency ravines
and sharp valleys and sharp minima
so that a little stream at the top of a
mountain
will be um will be cut carving its way
through very sharp
um trajectories um
and then meeting slower and slower and
wider and wider streams as it comes down
as it comes down the mountain
but also what happens is that as you
come down towards sea level
as you get to lower lower free energy
levels
the terrain itself becomes smoother so
all the minima
now have smaller curvature so that you
don't get those
sharp little landscape features uh that
you saw
high in the free energy or high in the
mountains anymore what you get a now
much
much more gentle landscape where
everything because it's a lower
altitude or a lower free energy has to
be smoother it has to have a
you know by occam's principle it has to
be it has to have less of a curvature
and what that affords is the latitude
for
the river now to start meandering around
like you know you know sometimes
following oxbow
uh legs and features that you that this
kind of meandering that you see
as a large river starts to um
wander and oscillate as as it gets
towards the estuary and gets towards the
sea
and it's that sort of wandering around
which is that if you like the sort of
the um
the permissive or the reflection of what
can happen
um with a low curvature um free energy
functional or objective function
which is in itself in the sense that if
the system is trying to minimize its
free energy and get
to those estuaries so it can do its once
slow wandering around
you get this critical slowing that you
see dynamically that characterizes
your all kinds of interesting um
uh behaviors from sort of um avalanches
in
neuronal avalanches in the brain through
to the markets
in the old days this might have been
known as catastrophe theory um
but you know it's the same notion that
when we're close to the edge of
instability
which means we have the latitude to
explore different
states on some objective function
um that we wouldn't have if we were
stuck in a rut and committed to a
particular solution
and we've overfit the data for example
or we've got trapped in a local minima
so that's that's one that's one thing
that there is another
aspect though which um we haven't
touched upon which
in um i think nicely follows on from
this notion of the
you know getting the generative model
right so if you remember the
free energy functional or the model
evidence needs a model
in order to have so the model can have
the evidence
and of course you know most of the time
you're dealing with
models that have unknown states such as
models that underwrite things like
kalman filters
unknown parameters such as the generated
models that might do weather forecasting
um but there's another level which is
the very structure of the model itself
so
you know even um
even if i knew all the states um the
time
varying unknowns generated by a
particular model
and even if i knew exactly all the
particular
connections strengths and rate constants
and every all the other parameters and
contingencies i
you would need to know to uh to make
this model predict the perfect
data perfect explanation for for for
these
for this observed world
i may not know the structure of the
model so if i was doing say deep
learning
and i wanted to build um a deep
convolutional network how many how many
layers do i use
two four eight sixteen um
so these are really important
architectural structural problems that
are attributes of the model
but the model can always be scored given
some data
in terms of its free energy or elbow
evidence lower bound
which means there's always an answer if
you can
create a space of models to evaluate so
this is known as in
in cognitive neuroscience by people like
josh turner bound as structure learning
and it's the problem of basically
exploring the right structure of models
by
you're adding things in taking things
away collapsing things together you
talked about modularity before
that's a really important architectural
uh aspect of these models
usually cast in terms of factorization
uh exploiting conditional dependencies
to
get simpler models that you can have a
modular architecture in the generator
model
um so all of these structural the
hierarchical depth the degree of
lateral factorization or modularity the
number of parallel streams
the number of nonlinearities all of
these things
need to be optimized to get the good
model the free energy minimizing model
so how would you do that and it's at
this point that you come back to
disorder and chaos so one really
efficient way of exploring a space of
models
is to actually exploit the um
the you know the the the um
the chaotic dynamics that you get um
or certainly stochastic dynamics that
you that you get for example
um in natural um selection um
the you know you could you could you
could um
take arguments from uh evolutionary
theory and again coming back to stu
kaufman
um in terms of his formulation of
selection for selectability
i don't know have you come across this
second order selection
no actually the way that i encountered
stuart kaufman was reading about his
expansion of schrodinger's what is life
and then schrodinger opposed to three
questions that is how
whatever he posts three questions and
stuart kaufman answers the second
two so two and three all right i didn't
read much about him afterward and i'll
ask you about start afterwards but do
you what do you have to tell me what the
questions well that sounds very
interesting
yeah sure i i'm talking about his work
um
um on sort of um um more sort of
artificial life
um that speaks to this edge of chaos and
the
the necessary role of disorder or chaos
in any
evolving system that needs to explore
different ways of being
um so it's interesting because of course
you can now
um the degree of um
chaos that you bring to the table the
degree of mutation for example
you know um there will be an optimum
degree of mutation that depends upon the
volatility of the environment
and the degree at which you exploit or
leverage
chaos now becomes subject to selected
pressure
um and um just as an aside you can
always recast
selective pressure as basically a
pressure to minimize
free energy uh if you read free energy
as the you know the adaptive fitness of
any of any
uh phenotype in a in a
natural setting natural selection so
what he's saying is that there is
an optimal degree of um
changeability and chaotic exploration of
of any modern space or any wave
wave being um the to my mind provides a
very nice
um perspective on this tendency for
self-organized criticality that
we actually move ourselves to the edge
of chaos
just to position ourselves so we can
explore and make sure there are no
better ways of doing things so i think
that that that aspect of
your own the right mixture of order
versus disorder
order versus chaos you know comes at out
at the level of the structured learning
itself from the sort of
the repertoires of different alternative
hypotheses about
you know modeling our world or making
making decisions in that world
okay when we're modeling this world most
of the time what we do is we look at
nature
and then we see principles and then
sometimes we can infer about the brain
so
let's say we understand how atoms
assemble then we understand the
molecules symbol then we understand
cells and so on so obviously it's not as
simple as that but then
you in one of your interviews posed
another mechanism that is that we can
look at the brain structures
and we can infer about the world so for
example i believe you said that the fact
that an axon
is long and reaches out is a reflection
of
spooky action at a distance or action at
a distance and then i was thinking well
what about the hierarchical structures
of
pyramidal neurons do they reflect that
our world is
hierarchical and first of all why would
that be the case why does it have to be
mirrored second of all
there's another structure that is the
biohemispheric structure of the brain so
one is
i know there's a fair bit of myths about
the brain left brain versus right brain
but there's also some truth to some
parts of that now ian mcgillcrist
i'm sure you're aware of his work or his
name sounds familiar
he explored that as well so my question
is
what can you infer well why does it have
to be the case that your
internal structure of your brain would
mirror reality in some manner
and second what about the biohemispheric
structure what does that say about our
world okay well that that's a
really good question which could you
know could take us in a number of
different directions
um the notion that the
if you are in the game of um
predicting minimizing surprise
through the lens of minimizing
prediction error
then you want to generate a model that
can faithfully but
simply reproduce the kind of sensory
data sensory impressions that the world
is generating
so the formal structure of the
process that generates the sensory input
has to be to a certain level
recapitulated
on the inside in order to generate and
afford
those the right kind of predictions so
that is
a statement um uh really
i think um the good regulator theorem
which which arose
towards the end of the the cybernetics
movement by people um like ross ashby
um uh sort of you know regarded myself
as a father of self-organization this
notion that
every system that controls or regulates
its environment
must in essence be a model of that
environment
so there's an isomorphism between the
controller
and the controlled and that certainly is
the case
um uh is it sorry to interrupt i'm so
sorry
is it an isomorphism like is it exactly
mirrored because i recall when i was
speaking to bernardo castro he said
we can't model our reality exactly
because if we did
we would dissolve into an entropic soup
and then i said what do you mean and
then he said the argument was
it was too convoluted for him to state
at the time and i think he was referring
to you
so is it isomorphic or is it just no
you're absolutely
it's certainly not isomorphic because as
you save you if you want
i mean the best model in the world is
the world itself i mean that's that's a
tourism whichever
everyone celebrates and so um
no it's a it's a sufficiently good model
or an ultimately good model in the sense
that it's the simplest
um caricature of the system
or parts of the system the subspace
you're trying to control so
you know i still think it's um useful to
consider
um the good regulator theorem um
but you're right it's not not isomorphic
in any sense it's
an even lesser when you when you
consider that a lot of the time we
actually
build our own sensations when we move um
and certainly in terms of sensing our
own body
uh you know we are in charge of
basically creating that sensorium um
however let's just stick to the to your
original question
you know so no it's not it's not an
isomorphic but it certainly
has the right architecture to be able to
produce
a simplified summary or prediction of
what's going on
that is conserved every time around so
you're only interested in predicting um
things on
average so that you're revisiting
particular states so
you just need to get the gist of what's
going on
so it's a much simpler one but it still
must fundamentally have the same kind of
causal architecture
the same conditional dependencies and
you've highlighted
um a really important one which is the
um
the the symmetry between our two
hemispheres
the um you also mentioned this this um
which i've forgotten about which is the
or the very existence
of neural processes long thin
connections um that our neurons are
equipped with which you won't find
anywhere else in any other organ
um you know the liver doesn't have them
the
the heart to a certain extent does have
fibers but they're not they're not nice
and long
um which which you know just reading
the structure of the generative model is
telling you something about the kind of
universe
that's generating the data that this
model is trying to predict
tells you immediately you've got action
at a distance
which is not necessarily a given um but
it tells you that this creature
must contend with a world where there's
some kind of action at a distance
it can see things in the distance for
example so
you know the contention would be if you
had a
um a worm that could not
um see things at a distance then it
probably wouldn't have very long axons
um and it would be quite comfortable
having lots of short range
axons they were quite sufficient for
modeling a world where it's just
immediate contact and short-range
causality that's generating
its sensations okay
quick question so i'm speaking to a
camera right now and its sensor is
fairly flat
and yet it can pick up from far away it
can pick up a mountain
now i understand that the camera isn't
acting on the world are you saying that
if it was to have some embodied
enactment then
well it wouldn't use this sensor in the
way that it's formulated right now it
would use axons in some way
would use long wires in some way you'd
um
if you actually well okay let's pursue
that that analogy then so
um so you know let's pursue assume
you're going to be using
um some kind of vgi um
computer graphics to generate um um
you know um a visual scene that you
could
use in a movie so what that would
necessitate is basically a machine
with lots of wires because it's all
action at a distance
so you couldn't do it on a a computer
um that didn't have big buses
and the ability to to move data around
um in a way that would recapitulate
the um the action at a distance
that is necessary for um
um for
vgi so particularly sort of um you know
the ray tracing that's required um to
to basically you know render a scene
you know that's massively com you know
computer intensive that
requires a lot of if you like hardware
that you cannot do with just local
computing you actually have to do lots
of
lots of message passing yeah and we're
talking now about sort of the
architectures that computer scientists
would
would use so it's just that there are
certain computations you can do
um without sort of the other the kinds
of architectures you'd find in computer
science
that just involve local interactions but
as soon as you
have to actually generate virtual worlds
or worlds
um that they entail action distance you
get a different kind of connectivity
and a different kind of structure so
that's all i was really trying to
intimate
um intimate there um the
my favorite example is is before we turn
to the into hemispheric one is the um
a a a differentiation between a
a dorsal stream and a ventral stream
primarily concerned with what things are
and where they are and this speaks to
that modularity that we were talking
about earlier on that
somehow our brain has found
a really simplifying device to create a
modular architecture by
leveraging the conditional independences
between whatnots and awareness
in objects in the kind of universe we
live in so
put that simply there you're knowing
that this is
a cup doesn't tell me where it is
knowing
something is over there doesn't tell me
what it is
so that means that if i'm trying to
generate predictions i only need
i can have one part of my brain doing
the whoppness and the other part of my
brain doing the awareness
and then i can bring them together to
actually explain the sensory input
and that keeping things apart keeping
these parallel parallel streams apart
means i don't have to have the
complexity cost of all
the connections between them i don't
have to represent every object in every
position
in the world i can just represent um
your what it is and where it is and then
just bring the
bring them together as part of my
genitive models so that
that you know that tells you something
quite fundamental if i find a brain
that has this segregation into what and
where
i know that they live in a world of
objects where they
in their universe things don't really
things are conserved when they move
around
ah aha interesting
so um that brings us to the delicate
issue of why we've got symmetrical
brains
i think quite simply because we got
symmetrical bodies
um i think that you know
but then you may be asking why we've got
symmetrical bodies but sorry i'm not
going to try to answer that
well i was actually referring to the
asymmetry of the brains
all right that the left as let's say
ian mcgilchrist would say that the left
is more concerned with manipulation and
pinpointing
making definitive and the right is more
concerned with exploratory
motion so even actually at night time
when you're looking for your watch
or your clock you actually explore with
your
left hand because it's controlled by the
right brain naturally
you move you make more exploratory
movements with your left i'm not saying
anything you probably don't know
and then with your right most people are
right-handed and they like
to well whatever so then i was wondering
is that a reflection of what the world
is composed of or comprises in some
manner
and then also how does one know when one
is taking this too far so for example
just because the brain has a
morphological structure of foldiness and
gyruses and sulky and so on
doesn't mean the world is full d
or my experience is hilly
how does one know when to apply it and
when not to
so i was just you know thinking about
all your challenging questions
one by one um well i like the one about
the the world isn't folding that's very
nice
um uh and mystically one can make an
an analogy and say well the world is
complex and fractal-like and nothing is
ever the same and
and you can look at it from multiple
vantage points so it sounds to me more
like one is playing a linguistic game
in that example that i just gave rather
than actually giving
a property of the world that's reflected
in the
morphology of the brain yes yes um so i
i'd also just remembered that
i saw a presentation by colleagues of
mine recently that
actually interestingly made the
foldiness
um a possible reality um
but that's a distraction and a unique
and very exciting observation
but you're right so when i'm talking
about structure
i the only structure that matters is the
same kind of structure
that underwrites a markov blanket is
conditional dependencies
so i'm talking about a connectivity
architecture here i'm not talking about
the physical shape of the brain i'm just
talking about what is connected to what
is not connected
um so you know you you all i need is the
graph
if you like if you were a graph
theoretician i just need the adjacency
machines on the connectivity
usually the directed connectivity matrix
that's for me is what
what defines the structure so um
you know at that level
um the kinds of structures
that can be defined purely in terms of
the
adjacency or the edges on a graph are
things
like um the number of hierarchies
or the number of parallel streams or the
number of
modular um um uh
the number of uh um modules
uh or or uh clusters you know the degree
of small world is if you if you like
uh clustering indices i can't remember
all the um
the graphic terms for them but crucially
it's just that defined in terms of
connectivity
and i think um i think you can you can
within that remit and without going into
the world is
doesn't have cortical folds you know i
wish
within the remit of um
instantiating and biophysically
realizing
causal contingencies and associations uh
in terms of connections between um
biological systems in particular
neuronal systems i think i think you can
um i think you can actually play this
game and play it for quite a long time
in terms of the hierarchical depth and
in terms of this modularity and this
factorization that we're just talking
about and in particular the hierarchical
depth i think is
is a very important one because you know
you're asking me well why should the
world be hierarchically structured
but it is necessarily hierarchically
structured if one
um just considers a you know a
separation of temporal scales so
you know there just has to exist
in terms of a course grading um applied
to any dynamical system
um a progression of slower stuff
that is has a your more course grained
aspect
to it uh that you could add your know
you you could elaborate recursively um
you know in principle for you know for
an infinite number of levels
so there does exist causal structure out
there in
any sparsely connected um
in the dynamical sense
world that i think fully licenses an
interpretation of the corresponding
architecture
and in particular it's hierarchical
depth as somehow
mirroring or reflecting that
hierarchical structure out there
with the obvious example of course is is
um
all of that machinery that aspect of our
brains
that is devoted to providing an apt
generative model
for interpersonal interactions so
you know if one realizes that most of
our
lived world is or at least the
sensations
generated by that world are generated by
other creatures like me
namely you uh you know where they were
driving around in cars
walking in parks talking on zoom reading
books
99.9 of us our sensorim is
generated by another human being that is
like me
so that actually says there has to be a
lot of the
brain has to be devoted to modeling
me and people like me and making
inferences about me
and as soon as you start to get to this
um
think about what kinds of genitive
models would be
fit for purpose in in that context then
the imperatives to resolve uncertainty
are basically
the drives for me to understand you
so this epistemic part of the free
energy minimization
as a consequence of action translates
into
an imperative to understand the world
but the live world now with
is basically you in this instance i need
to understand you
how do i do that we have to have a
shared narrative what does that require
language
it could be maths it could be could be
english but that narrative has
many many different scales to it that
has itself a deep temporal structure
so there's the concept that i that we're
conveying
there's a temporal scale of the duration
of this of this
exchange there are much recursively much
finer
temporal structures in terms of the
structure of the sentence
the phrases that i'm using the words the
phonemes
all the way down to the millisecond by
millisecond
activation of your
sensory epithelia in your ears or my
neuromuscular junctions
controlling my articular articulatory
apparatus so we wouldn't be able to talk
to each other
or comply with this imperative to
resolve uncertainty
to explore the world that i have to
model
um without language and without a deep
genetic model with a deep
hierarchical structure there can be no
language there's a natural
if you like not pressure but there's
certainly
uh an easy way to understand why we have
deep generative models
in our brain in fact we do i mean you
know nearly
all the interesting connectivity all the
interesting architectural aspects
of brain connectivity speak to a
hierarchical organization at some level
it's cortical subcortical the very word
sub means below below is only an
attribute of hierarchy it can't be
any other thing you know the visual
hierarchy being the sort of
the the poster child for um very well
um defined subsumption hierarchies
but you know beyond that wherever you
look in the brain there is some
hierarchical organization where
where slow stuff is in training fast
stuff at the lower below
and then all the way down to the um to
the sensory
inputs on the uh the actuators or the
active
active outputs which are the fastest
parts and
okay so hierarchy is another way of
saying difference that can be compared
say that again so a hierarchy a
difference that can be compared
so these two are different but there's
no hierarchy between them if it's like
someone may say apples and oranges but
if it's between apples and two apples
then there's a hierarchy there because
there's a quantity that we can reduce
down and put a comparison between them
oh i see yeah no absolutely so the the
height the way i'm using hierarchy here
is certainly
um sort of so when people talk about say
deep learning um what they're talking
about is um
inference and classification under a um
under a hierarchical genitive model that
has a number of hidden layers
so the depth of the the learning machine
refers to how many layers you build
and so what you do is you put the data
in um
and then you try and explain it with one
there and then those explanations and
that you then try and explain it with a
layer
on top of that and then you keep on
going until ultimately you get to some
very very
coarse grain very abstract explanations
that are predicting if you like
the there below and then they're
unpacked to predict hierarchically
right down to the level of say pixel
elements in a tv screen or sort of um
you know some image that's been grabbed
so
the deep the hierarchical depth is
basically how many
subordinate layers do you have i see one
higher level providing getting
information from the lower level
but also providing um constraints
i'm saying well if this hierarch if this
context is in play
then i expect this kind of thing to
happen over here in that modality and
that kind of thing to happen over there
in that modality so it brings a
simplification
and a a better way of modeling provided
that you've got this hierarchical
structure
what you were talking about i think is
more the modularity of the sort of
is this a an apple or is this an orange
i think that
within the hierarchy within the depth
from sort of um
you know the lower level which are
usually at the level of the sensors and
the actuators
and the higher level um is usually um
the top of a pyramid
of course you know there isn't a pyramid
in the brain it's you can imagine it
more like a circle
and the center being being the deeper
parts of it
um so but there's a there's another
architectural structure which is um not
in the
the depth of the hierarchy from the
bottom of the circle say to the center
but actually the the different streams
you talk about the apples and oranges
and it's that
factorization that what awareness that i
was you know
hinting at before which is a lovely
example of
um you know things i know about oranges
are not relevant for things i know about
apples i mean
that's probably a silly example because
there are there are things that are
concerned but
things i know about fruit i'm not going
to be terribly useful for things i know
about tools
so i can actually have my genitive model
generating
a cascade of abstract
representations becoming more and more
detailed committed
right down to a picture of or a sound of
or
me moving this particular artifact but
of course
this artifact can be either a tool or a
face
you know or an apple a fruit
and because you've got you know these
conditional dependencies tools don't
behave like fruit
and i don't in particular um i don't
um actively engage with tools
in the same way that i engage with fruit
i eat fruit but i use tools
so it's likely that you get this the
separation through
this um this factorization or modular
parallel architecture
in the setting of a hierarchical
composition
so these are really important sort of
sort of architectural principles if you
have to actually build
or understand the brain but also if you
wanted to build
a you know a conscious artifact or an
intelligent artifact
you'd have to equip it with a with this
you know with both a deep genitive model
but also
had this sort of um these parallel
streams to them
which brings us back to the right brain
versus left brain i still don't
i don't have a neat answer for you i'm
afraid but you're right i mean
you know language lateralization is a
classic um
a classic uh and conserved
aspect of our brains but i can't think
of a first principle account as to why
that
might be the case you mentioned the word
narrative that we have to have a shared
narrative now were you saying that we
have to have a shared narrative
in order to have peace between us or in
order to interact or in order to
understand one another
and then also does that narrative have
to be encapsulated in language or can it
be
embodied because i assume that animals
can get along
and they don't have language at least
not the way we do and presumably we
didn't have language
prior to a million years ago
yeah we got along yeah well i meant it
in exactly the same the sense that you
um you intimated there so
um yeah it it is just there if we
have a shared narrative um that i'm i'm
now
using narrative to describe a generative
model
that entails um sequences of things that
happen over time
so it's a model of sequences um
that usually has a deep deep temporal
structure to it
so if i want to understand you
and i want to communicate with you um in
order to understand you and to
and to ask you questions to understand
more about your
your intentional stance your knowledge
then i'm going to need
to infer what you're thinking
and i can do that if i know what i'm
thinking
but only and then under the assumption
that you're using the same kind of model
as me
so we're both using the same code or
singing from the same hymn
sheet so you know when you start to
model this you don't
you well we have models of of of um
linguistic exchange which are cast in
terms of
simple games of 20 questions so you know
one agent has to ask another agent
um through linguistic exchange but it
does depend
depend upon them both committing to the
same
generative model of this linguistic
exchange in the meaning
a simpler a simpler set of simulations
um arises when you think about sort of
just birds singing to each other so they
can recognize con specifics
so you know what that's quite that's
much easier to simulate
when you just have two dynamical systems
talking to each other and they're both
now becoming trained to show
synchronization of chaos than we were
talking about before
in a different context but here in the
service of mutual predictability
so another way of thinking about what's
the best way to minimize surprise
surprise or self-information when
exchange with another
is to make sure that i only exchange
with other people exactly like me
because i can predict exactly what
you're going to do next because i know
exactly what i'm going to do next
i'm doing it so you know we could be
singing or talking together
clearly we take turns but there are
situations where we could be actually
singing in the choir together but i can
only
sing with people that have a
sufficiently similar generative model to
me
that makes it um that licenses
the use of my model of how
this kind of creature interacts with the
world
uh license licenses its use
as a model of how you are interacting
with the world and
interacting with interacting with me so
that's what i meant by shared narrative
just
just a shared or conserved generative
model
between um creatures that typically
um act together in terms of things like
joint attention or
familial bonds or sort of con specifics
in an evolutionary
context um you know
that generalizes um in terms of your
cultural takes on
um uh niche construction you know
the existence of things like signs and
traffic lights and elephant and desire
paths
these are all manifestations of um you
know
living sharing a world with other
creatures like myself
that after a while there they become
very
efficient very simple ways of
communicating
possibly as you say don't involve spoken
language and non-verbal communication
is clearly an incredibly important part
of that but even beyond that
just the fact that we have a shared
commitment to
stopping when a traffic signal or light
goes red
you know that's a shared narrative we
have that enables us to drive around and
occupy the same streets
when some of us are driving and some of
us are walking or both of us are driving
so that's what i meant by shared
narrative is sort of you know a common
a common generative model of how to live
in this world
with things like me interesting
interesting okay now it can't simply be
just shared there has to be some other
criteria only because
me and you can still share the same
model that says that you're an enemy and
i'm supposed to kill you and i'm
and you're supposed to kill me so then
it's not just shared that allows us to
be peaceful cohabitants and i was
wondering
then do you think religion is an attempt
to make a hypothesis or
or to generate possibilities as to
generative models that
a large class of people could share and
minimize the suffering of
both the society and the individuals at
the same time
yeah i haven't thought deeply about this
but that's a very plausible
very plausible explanation for why um
religious narratives have have emerged
and that's so successful
in maintaining themselves um so
you know just in in terms of a simple
analysis
of the minimizing complexity arguments
that we were rehearsing before
your if you want to find a really simple
explanation that accommodates a lot of
difficult to explain stuff very
accurately then
a a deity that can cause all this stuff
is a really simple explanation
and you know if it accurately explains
your sensorium and your world
then it's it's a beautiful example of a
very parsimonious hypothesis
now it may not be sufficiently accurate
for
a scientist who does not accept
you know a religious explanation for
this or that
but if you are not um if you are not um
sampling that kind of sensory
information or
that kind of scientific data then that
doesn't matter
um because you know you only need to
explain what you need to explain
so just as um just as a broad um
comment upon religious beliefs um
and i think you can generalize that to
societal norms
you know just ways of behaving the right
way to behave
um you know these are just simple
hypotheses
that explain a lot of my behavior and a
lot of your behavior in a really
parsimonious way
and therefore they have big evidence
although free energy because
they provide simple explanations um so
but you're bringing something else to
the table which is which is
an interesting one which i haven't
thought about which of course these
kinds of
um hypotheses are easy to share as well
in virtue of their simplicity um and
there's always going to be benefit in
having um a shared or conserved
or a common genitive model um provided
as you say that
we're all cooperating we're all acting
as con specifics um
it's interesting to um and you know so
in answer to your question
i am sure that if you simulated multiple
agents all free energy minimizing all
trying to predict each other
in the most efficient way possible and
then one of them had
this simple hypothesis of a religious
or a ideological or theological sword
that made sense of lots of things to
which everybody could subscribe
you'd suddenly see the consolidation and
the emergence of that
of that aspect of the generative model
absolutely and that would render
everybody
mutually predictable so everybody would
be reducing their surprise
um you know and that would
mathematically be expressed as a
you know a collective decrease in free
energy or an
increase in the adaptive fitness in the
sense of you know
increasing the marginal likelihood of
finding that phenotype around
if you're simulating multiple
generations um
but the well in that case that would be
trivially correct in saying that there's
a deity because
you're the simulator yes
well that's an interesting hypothesis
which um interestingly if you
um if you do philosophy of course then
you've got the brain in the vat
thought experiment which indeed actually
has that exactly
as an alternative hypothesis uh to
confound the uh
um you know the philosophy of of of
realism versus skepticism
um but coming to you to your interesting
point that you know
what happens if my genitive model is
that you know you're my enemy
you're going to you're going to cause me
surprises
i think that's that's an interesting one
you know the level at which we
simulate these things really only
addresses um
cooperation and systems that have
different components and trying to find
their place
with a shared narrative um
so you know what one would predict is
that if there were
um the the there were other kinds of
agents that were not like you
um then you would certainly be have to
represent them
in virtue of the fact that they're not
lucky you wouldn't be able to
communicate with them
so you know my prediction would be that
you know whether it's a theological or a
political
or other kind of um commitment
um if there's an in-group and an out
group for any one given individual
it is highly unlikely that there will be
a shared language
or indeed a big transaction of
communication between these two groups
so there will be a mark off blanket if
you like between the between the
in-group and the aggro
the blues and the reds the uh um you
know wherever you go
an interesting observation which is not
mine but i've heard a number of people
make is that the
the only um stable
um non-equilibrium for that in-group out
group is a 50-50 split
so the you know in the language of
theoretical
biology the evolutionary stable
strategies for
opponents um is a 50-50 split
which is borne out you know time and
time again in terms of what do you mean
a 50-50 split of what population
of the number of people that would
identify with one group versus another
group
yeah so it's become voting interesting
yeah so
um brexit versus non-brexit in the in
the uk or trump versus biden
um in the most recent american elections
you know wherever you get something
where um
that where there is contention where you
could commit to one side or the other
side
the only if you like contentions or
dialectics which seem to survive
is when there's a roughly 50 50 split
between you um so okay so in other words
the fact that we stably defer somewhat
down the line on many important issues
is adaptive
yep for the collective as a whole it's
just maintaining a non-equilibrium
steady state yeah i mean adaptive in
their deflationary sense that
you know that is one way to to to
maintain
you know a uh an extended
non-equilibrium
um you know where now we're talking
about markov blankets and mark off
blankets and sort of applying
blankets to um you know to multiple
agents
there's one quote that i love that i i
try to live by and it's
only the shallowest of minds would think
that in great controversy one side is
mere folly
i'm sure you've heard that before i
haven't heard that particular one but
i've heard something similar which which
is
okay so do you believe in free will and
if so how do you define it
so um free will um yup um
i mean you ask do i believe in it
there's certainly space for um free will
um in the um the realization of a free
energy principle
in sentient artifacts at many levels um
you you when you actually come to write
down and simulate
or build little toy um agents
you very quickly realize that the most
interesting in fact the only
interesting behaviors um that you can
simulate
arise when you write down the generative
models
as containing um autonomous dynamics
usually of a
chaotic sort so the reason i
i use the word autonomous dynamics is
that
you know mathematically speaking there's
a sort of free will in the autonomy
there's even in a deterministic setting
there
is um um you know
an unpredictability given the initial
conditions
um that cannot be determined so um
in that sense there has to be a
mathematical kind of of free will
at play um the the um
the other the other sort of take i guess
on free will is it comes back to what we
were talking about before about
you know making our own sensations
creating our own sensorium so if you
remember that
um the you know
from the point of view of minimizing um
prediction error as surprise there are
two ways i can do that i can
change my mind so that my predictions
are more
like what i'm sensing and that would be
a minimization of particular through
perception
but there's another way of doing that
minimizing the prediction
i can actually just change what i'm
sampling to make the sensations more
like the predictions
so that's you know that's action in the
service of minimizing surprise or
prediction
but what that means is that my actions
are basically in enslaved
to where they can fulfill my predictions
so they are in the service of um
fulfilling prophecies so collectively
action perception is a self-fulfilling
prophecy
and in that sense i think you know um
you can
find free will you know if if we are
creating our own worlds and our own um
sensory inputs we're constructing our
sensorium
uh who else is doing it no so in that
very
simple um i won't say deflationary but
simple account of free will
then i i can't see how it can be any
other way really
i had there's something that i've been
wanting to study for quite some time and
i've been making
extensive notes on which is
self-fulfilling prophecies i find it to
be an extremely interesting area
of research the fact that you can have
them
it's like you have a model of the world
and
most of the time what you want to do is
make sure that your model comports with
reality but then it's as if there are
these blank spots in reality
where whatever you think if you think
there's a chair there then a chair
becomes
i know that that's an extreme example
but what i mean is that
if you imagine that your wife loves you
then you're going to act in a manner
that makes her love you more and if you
mistrust and so on so on so they're
self-fulfilling so it's as if there's
these lacunas in the world
that whatever you think is there becomes
there i wanted to know what your
free energy principle had to say about
self-fulfilling prophecies i imagine
quite a quite a lot but
i don't not sure if we have enough time
do you have any quick notes on
well i mean the way that you just
articulated that is it's spot on from
the point of view of the free energy
principles so we
we often use the phrase action is there
to realize and fulfill uh the prophecies
supplied
by the brain yeah it is literally a way
of
of creating your own sensorium in virtue
of
self uh realizing and um you know
self-fulfilling prophecies
you know i think that and the question
is can you keep on doing that
um in the face of a particular
environment that may allow you to do
that or may not and in particular
if you do it lots of other people who
are also
trying to pursue and self-fulfill their
their their purposes so
like what are the limitations of it yeah
yeah so
you know i i think that that's
absolutely right and it also
speaks to um you know seeing stuff which
is not there
um um starts to talk uh
brings us into the world
[Music]
of false inference and delusions and
hallucinations and
the kinds of um fulfilling self
sorry self-fulfilling prophecies of a
perceptual sort that people with
things like autism or schizophrenia
might be subject to so
you can go too far but on the other hand
you know there are many people who um
now
consider perception basically as sort of
hallucinations that are entrained by
by sensory input that your what we
actually see is
is it's sort of you know a product of
the hypotheses about what best explain
what's going on
and there are occasions when we can get
those hypotheses wrong
and that we have we're then subject to
illusions for example in psychophysics
or hallucinations um
and indeed delusions you know if we've
taken some psychedelic drugs or that we
have
conditions such as say schizophrenia so
then is schizophrenia a pathology of
free will
i don't think so no no i i think it's a
pathology of
of um that can be understood as a false
inference but i i don't
think that there's any um
uh aspect of um um
that would enable you to sort of isolate
free will as the
as the locus of that false inference
there's certainly a lot of a lot of work
suggesting that it
that the people with schizophrenia when
they are
acutely psychotic may have difficulties
um inferring who did that so assignment
of
agency so in the sense that you know who
will
that was it you or me there may be a
slight confusion
so i if i say something to myself i may
have
actually you said it you put that
thought into my head so
you know that's just your a false
attribution of agency
um so in that sense perhaps you could
say that that is a form of
disorganized free will um but certainly
the
people with schizophrenia that i have
treated or worked with in the past
um you know i think they would have a
sense of self
and um you know a sense of free will
which which would be indistinguishable
from uh
from yours and mine you know i know that
we have to wrap up at some point soon
and i wanted to bring this up i didn't
know how
but i'll just tell you quickly the a few
months ago maybe i'll even take this out
of the
actual clip but a few months ago january
february i was
i woke up in the middle of the night and
then i had a conversation with my wife
it was minor
neutral wasn't positive or negative and
then as i was going back to sleep she
either said yes or okay
or she could have not said it but i was
in this hypnagogic
almost sleep-like state and i've never
had a panic attack in my life but for
some reason
i wasn't sure if she said okay or yes or
whatever it was or if it was in my own
head
and then i thought am i am i psychotic
am i getting
schizophrenia i don't know why it's not
like that was a background anxiety of
mine before maybe it was maybe it's
latent but
then i started to have a panic attack
because i didn't want to hear
anything and i felt like i may be able
to will myself to hear something by
telling myself
don't hear then i'm like well what would
it sound like if i were to hear
then it's like no no don't go down there
because you may hear a voice
and i don't want to go i don't want to
be crazy i don't want to be psychotic
a couple days later i had another panic
attack almost based on the worry
that i'm going to be psychotic rather
than
i am at all and and i'm i've been afraid
to search
about schizophrenia because i don't want
to read that i have the symptoms of it
and
there's nothing else other than that i
may have heard my wife say okay or yes
in a state where i was
about to sleep and that she actually may
have in fact said it
or not i talked to my doctor about this
on the phone because it's
kovit and she said oh kurt well you can
hear many things you can hear
music when you're about to sleep you can
your foot can feel like you're about to
fall off and you
so don't worry about that and i found
that when i talk about it i feel much
more at ease
but ever since then for three months
carl for three months
at night time i've had such a difficult
time falling asleep
because i'm afraid of my own mind i
can't let myself be
alone with my own thoughts because i'm
afraid of what i might find
and it's created such anxiety in me that
i while i can't rely on any
benzodiazepine to sleep because that can
just put you in a
that'll create way worse problems so i
have to find some way of sleeping
without any
medication besides maybe melatonin
that's difficult
and i'm just not sure what to do with
that issue i brought this up on one of
my podcasts because
i feel like there are plenty of people
who may be experiencing what i'm
experiencing
but but people don't talk about it it
turns out when i did talk about it many
people in the comments section said
i can't believe you've been going
through this that's i've been going
through something similar
when i study about consciousness and so
on for this for these types of
interviews
i feel like i don't know what reality is
anymore because there's so many
different theories
and so that is destabilizing me on top
of what i've already been feeling and
i'm unsure what to do about it
and i just want to know what what advice
do you have i know that that's
extremely personal question but what
what do you recommend that i do
or not do well ironically you've just
done it
um um so um
now you i i i'm responding as in my role
as a psychiatrist not not obviously
author of
the free energy principle although much
of the free energy principle was
actually inspired by
exactly the questions that you're
contending with you know
how do i maintain a sense of self
which is the most important part of my
narratives
explain explain me and what can go wrong
when you have
um psychosis i think the first thing to
say
is that
[Music]
there have been an enormous number of
people
um around the world during um
lockdown and during the coronavirus
crisis with reduced
social contacts and changing points of
reference so
your old narratives your old models are
just not fit for purpose
and in a sense you've got to be able to
grieve for the things what that
your the way that things were and it's
quite
frightening to actually relearn how to
live even for a few months
um you're in in a new covered world and
certainly if there's been
um you know so changes in in social
distancing on the way that you interact
with people
and i should say also when and if
you um have to unlock that will also be
very uh you know
anxiety provoking as well because of the
uncertainty you've got to really learn
how to do it
so lots of my colleagues have had um
psychotic breaks
um and you i i talking to you i think
it's highly unlikely that you have any
form of psychosis
or indeed an acute psychotic episode
just by your composure
your theory of mind um a lot of other
non-verbal cues
however i do have many colleagues who've
actually had an acute psychotic
episode uh in response to this um
i been you know a lot of my close
colleagues have um
and it's perfectly natural they usually
last about sort of
um you know sort of a few weeks to a
month or two
um may respond to medication if if if
the person is becoming
sufficiently agitated or they're
worrying their their the close family
um you know it
needs containment pharmacologically
that's certainly viable if it gets that
far
usually it doesn't but the important
thing to know is this is perfectly
normal
you know um even if you haven't had a
psychotic episode if you had had
it's lots of people are going through
this which brings me to
the answer to your question um you can
certainly talk to your gp
um and talk to health care professionals
and mental health care professionals
and um there will be the option of
medication uh either to help with sleep
or to
if you actually did have a psychotic um
break
to take the edge off that and enable
everybody to cope with
you know with the consequences that's
always an option should you want to go
for it and you shouldn't feel
ashamed of doing that or in any way
hesitant
i have to say that the nature of these
episodes is such that
it won't be the person who has the
psychotic episode
who knows that they they need
containment and looking after
of a particular kind it's usually the
the next of kin their children their
parents or
or their wife or their husband uh who
has to take the initiative to
to bring in support and help to get that
done and that help is there
the very fact you're worrying about it
because you're
you're almost by definition it can't be
psychotic because you
you've got inside uh so just by worrying
about it i'm
afraid uh takes you off that list um but
it doesn't mean to say the anxiety
doesn't go away doesn't mean
you can't you're not actually uh
psychotic and the other thing which
which
really helps um is just what you've
already said
it it's basically sharing in the group
so you know
the angst that these things generate and
the you know whether it's a psychotic
break or not always worrying about it or
not
everybody's going through this um and
being able to share that
in a group is uh can be enormously
therapeutic
for everybody in in the group you know
so if you can set up
by sharing a safe environment within
which
to share these experiences and anxieties
and by safe i mean very clearly bounded
so it starts at a particular time and it
finishes exactly
one hour later so you've got this
boundary so that
anything that comes out in that context
can't spill over
and affect um and can be put back in the
box
but you know there's going to be a box
next week or tomorrow
with a very very carefree time you know
who's going to be there
or you know what kind of people are
going to be there so boundaries are very
very important when it comes to group
therapy that
that in my in my experience that's the
most effective
kind of talking therapy in this
situation
how do you get a group together you have
to say well this is a
a thing um how do you do that you just
have to declare you have to come out say
i'm upset by this i can't get to sleep
because of this
this you know you know if i'd told
myself these worries a year ago i
thought i was stupid but these are real
worries they're stopping me
thinking i can't you know just saying
that out loud
means that other people now are aware
that this is a thing
and it's something that can be talked
about so when i said you've just done it
by just going public in this kind of
interview
is the first move the next move is then
to find
um you know a a a network
or a structure that will support um
either therapist-led or self-help groups
usually
small enough that you actually have the
the intimacy of a small group dynamic
you know so not more than 12 people
you usually about so eight people with
or without a therapist
you don't need the therapist but it's
useful um you know if somebody is
just to get used to the importance of
boundaries and
um and group dynamics but it's not
necessary if
you know the important things you're
getting together in a bounded way
um to to you know to to share
and um and to just in
a completely open and non-judgmental way
um
tell other people how what they are
saying makes you feel
um and just use them to reflect
literally like a mirror
you know so come back to the shared
narrative again and you can
you can get a long way with that so um
that that's what i would recommend that
you you you know
somebody in your position may well feel
that perhaps you should start
um an initiative along these lines or
actually start you
you should take the initiative and
actually set up
a discussion group or a self-help group
um
but if not then certainly look around on
the web and i'm sure you'll find
um you know some somebody over the past
few months um and uh we will have
started this
um and be mindful
that you should tell your wife
if you do get a psychotic yeah just kind
of get the doctors into
to get you medicated because that'll go
away in about three weeks once you
you know if you just take the right kind
of medication it's not a big thing
you know i repeat it's happened to
several of my colleagues and friends
um and you know they're back in the
saddle now
and it's been a useful experience
sometimes people get um
they get more creative they go slightly
manic
i don't sense that in you but um
i do notice that when i was having my
high anxiety periods right after the
initial episode
that i saw many more connections almost
like i imagine
when you're on lsd or a psychedelic that
everything is imbued with meaning
that every other sentence someone would
say in a movie i'm like oh that's so
deep
that it makes me want to cry almost now
that's not there
i still do see connections but i tend to
have always seen connections to some
degree anyway yeah so i mean
these episodes um will either just
reveal innate sort of
you know ways of thinking and seeing and
making sense of the world
in particular pro-social context um
but but certainly you know what i was
going to say is that
there can be some um if you keep a
record of these
if you can if you just see associations
and links and just
keep a documentary every record of it it
may actually be something quite useful
either to go back to as a you know an
essay in the way that you saw the world
in that particular state of that
particular time but sometimes you
actually get some
quite profound insights you know again a
number of my colleagues actually do
suffer from manic depressive psychosis
uh and of course if you look at the
history of of your creative people
in both the you know the arts and the
sciences uh
you know you're you're on this edge of
chaos
this the the instability that is
associated with um
with psychosis so it's not an
unproductive
time um you know if you are if you did
get close to the edge then then make
sure you keep a very
um if you can keep a very clear document
doc document what happened to you and
everything you can
this would be nice for you to go back to
next year yeah i
definitely take notes on all my thoughts
i've done so for years anyway
i'm always constantly saying i can't say
now cause it'll turn on but
okay and then the name of my device and
then i say make notes and so on so on
yeah okay well thank you so much doc i
want to say doctor thank you so much
professor you are a doctor obviously
professors
thank you so much carl there was a
statement that you said before
many times actually it's that you are
your own existence proof
can you explain what that is what that
means
it is one of those deflationary um
summaries of the free energy principle
that says
the very fact you exist tells you a lot
about
the mechanics and the things that you
must do or the properties that you must
possess
in order to exist so you turn that on
its head
and the fact that you exist is proof of
your own existence again in this
tautological sense um
you could also read it as one way of um
encapsulating the notion of
self-evidencing so
if you read um
self-organization as
a system trying to minimize its
free energy or maximize the evidence
for its models of the world then
what you can say is that these kinds of
systems
change in such a way to increase the
evidence for their own
existence so it comes to
um very close to the notion of this
self-fulfilling prophecy that you know
i expect to exist um
and i'm going to act on the world in a
way
that solicits or secures evidence for
that existence and if i have a good
model of that world then i will be
successful
in soliciting that evidence and in so
doing
i will persevere and i will simply exist
and i look as if i'm self evidencing and
of course
evidence for what well evidence to prove
that i exist
so it's it's a rather sort of um cheeky
um way of celebrating the
the tautology of existence in the in in
the sense that
just existing is really all you need to
know and you can
spin off everything else all the
attributes of
artifacts particles people plants that
exist
just from their very existence
what happens if you start looking for
evidence that you don't exist
like let's say you're on the eastern end
of the philosophical spectrum
and you say that the eye is illusory
that maybe this is all a dream
whatever that may be what happens is
that
is there a system that can do that or
you look for evidence of your
non-existence can you think yourself
into non-existence i know that
likely not but please run with that idea
oh well
you know it's a wonderful question i
mean yes i think you
you could certainly um think yourself
into non-existence i mean just
you know a trivial thought experiment
would be somebody who's a very
committed meditator who forgets to drink
or eat
and dies through dehydration um so no it
is certainly possible
it's a wonderful question because it it
speaks to something in
um philosophy called the dark room
problem
so it is certainly possible to simulate
in silico in computers and agents that
deliberately
do not believe that they exist and
will avoid sampling data that would
otherwise um provide evidence for their
existence
and what that translates into is
essentially um
an artifact or a creature that
turns off the lights it you know
deliberately avoids any
information from the world and
sequesters itself from the world but in
so doing of course
um there are profound implications for
its homeostasis
and you know from a sensory point of
view it
hides away in dark corners and is now
subject to the dark room
problem um but at the same time
it will not be able to maintain its
markov uh blanket
and ultimately it will dissipate so if
it doesn't comply
with the existential principles that
maintain
its structure and form and its
organization technically
if it doesn't um comply with the
principles that
underwrite the maintenance of a markov
blanket then that markov blanket will
cease to exist and so
will you if you are that markov blanket
so
you know it's practically a very very
interesting
question because um it all rests upon
having a good
generative model of the world so you
know
there's a sort of dual dependency here
that you know
it looks as if creatures that or systems
more generally that exist
are seeking out evidence for their
internal model
of how the world works and how the world
generates its
sensory samples and that's
only an apt explanation for
self-organization
if the generative model is a fair
or a good enough explanation for the way
that those sensory samples are generated
um technically that's an idea which
dates back to the inception of
cybernetics
in the early half of the 20th century
known as a good regulator theorem that
in order to regulate to to control to
survive
in your environment you have to be
effectively a model of that environment
so
your whether you're a thermostat or um
or a person you know your structure
and the way that you exchange with the
environment
under a model that environment only
works
when you are a good model of that
environment
when you say generative model what's the
difference between a generative model
and just a model
um well genetic model is just a
technical term yeah strictly speaking it
it's just a specification of the
probabilistic relationship between
causes and consequences so
you literally you write down um a
probability density or a probability
distribution over causes and
consequences
and that allows you then to evaluate the
evidence
in some data for that model
so in this instance the causes are
unobservable sometimes referred to
as latent or hidden states say of a
world
and the consequences are observable
consequences
say sensory samples that we solicit with
our sensory epithelia
our eyes our ears or indeed our
our interception so the genitive model
read like that is just a probabilistic
specification
of how hidden or latent states hidden
behind say a markov blanket
generate observable consequences and if
you've got that model
then you can assess how likely
those sensory samples those sensations
as sensory impressions
were under your model and if they were
very likely you're not going to be
surprised
and you know that you've got a good
model of the world if you're constantly
surprised
unable to predict then you've got a bad
model of the world
and remember that surprise can also be
used as prediction error
so if you constantly subject yourself
actively to lots of prediction errors
you're going to be constantly surprised
in the state of high free energy
but think about what that means these
are not just prediction errors
in fact they are not prediction errors
of a sort of personal sort
you know a propositional thing i could i
could say oh i didn't expect that
these are sort of um fundamental
deviations from your expectations like
your bodily temperature
um the amount of blood sugar that you
your
your circulation is currently supplying
so when these get
out of physiological bounds you start to
literally disintegrate and die
and your markov blanket dissolves so
it's important to keep these
prediction errors within bounds or
in the language of the free energy
principle to you to keep on top
of your surprise self-information
or free energy all words for essentially
the same thing
okay what do you make of donald
hoffman's ideas on consciousness
i know that's broad right yeah
i had a mentor once called um jerry
edelman as a nobel laureate uh
famed for uh understanding the
evolutionary basis of
um our immune systems
uh uh he used to call me an intellectual
thug because i didn't
know anything outside of my own sphere
so if you tell me um what uh
yeah so forget about that forget about
because in order for me to say that it
would take too much time in them
and i probably wouldn't do it service
okay how about orchestrated objective
reduction from
penrose roger penrose stewart hammer off
if you've heard of them
yes yes yes certainly um so
yeah i certainly read um roger penrose's
uh
uh emperor's new mind yes the emperor's
new mind
um so um so what what what
sorry can you repeat well yeah what do
you think what do you think about it
does it comport with your theory
does it contradict it do you think it's
too unfalsifiable do you like it do you
think it's creative like what are your
broad thoughts about it
um i think it's entertaining um so i'm
going to lump that in
with um quantum theories of
consciousness or you know
um which is entertaining
um i don't see it as a serious
contender that offers any explanatory
power in terms of sentient behavior
i should say of course the you know my
work um
with the free energy principle and
things like active inference
these are not theories of consciousness
they can certainly be deployed
to set some parameters on questions that
arise in consciousness
uh research but in and of themselves
that they're not there is
um or principles that would underwrite
consciousness
um having said that
you know they do tell you where the
mechanics
of um the bayesian mechanics the physics
of sentience
lie in the physical world and it is not
at the quantum level
um so you know from the perspective of a
theory of every
space thing and the you know there
are there is a a range um
you can formalize mathematically under
things like the renormalization group
of things you can have very very small
things that have
very large amplitude random fluctuations
very very fast things
you can have very very big things very
slow things very cool things
that where the the other randomness
averages the way
so you know one can envisage this as a
spectrum between quantum mechanics
um at the very fast small
end and classical mechanics at the very
very
slow large end of the song that would
describe the the orbits of heavenly
bodies
um which means that you um
you you ask well where do where do we
fit and we
being um biotic systems that
show a particular kind of
self-organization that we would
associate with
um with life um and
it's in that it's in that intermediate
zone where
both the um the you know
the random fluctuations and um
what underwrites classical mechanics
which is this solenoidal
um circular motion that doesn't actually
change
surprisal or the marginal likelihood
that's where we live
so we know it's not at the quantum level
so we know that sentient behavior
and by implication sentience um cannot
be found at the quantum level
in the same sense it cannot be found in
the motion of the heavenly bodies
simply because they're too cool they
don't have the right kind of eye
tingency they're right
um if you like an adaptation the
challenges
the existential challenges that might um
destroy their mark off blankets are
simply
not in play and at the quantum level um
there's effectively no interesting
itinerancy that
is that defines non-equilibrium steady
state
so if i was responding oh no i'm not but
if i was responding to
a physicist asking asking that question
what you what i would be saying would be
that if we consider life
to be um self-organization
to some form of non-equilibrium far from
equilibrium
uh non-organization then stipulatively i
am
saying that we have to account for this
non-dissipative there
these non dissipative dynamics that are
mathematically
the solenoidal part if they are dwarfed
by random fluctuations that you find in
quantum physics
then you know we're not talking about
anymore um non-equilibrium we're talking
about equilibria we're talking about
solutions to the scrolling wave equation
so you know i re in conclusion you know
quantum neurobiology is entertaining
it's
interesting um but it's just not the
right place to
um to you know create
a uh mechanics of um
of sentient behavior and by that you
know i would guess that
that precludes it from being an apt
description of conscious artifacts
is one to understand the free energy
principle as giving
any indication as to what consciousness
is so for example the self-evidencing
is that consciousness or is it when it's
minimizing the free energy or is it the
fact that it
has a markov blanket because when i was
looking at the nodes
any point you can define a markov
blanket too so it doesn't
seem like the fact that there exists a
markov blanket means it's conscious
so what are the conclusions one is to
take from reading your free energy
principle
that someone can draw for consciousness
yeah
um right yeah yeah i
i i mean this is again an excellent
question because it's one being posed
um around the world as we speak you know
so
people like the uh john templeton
foundation are sort of earnestly looking
at ways to sort of
um put up for example the free energy
principle against integrated information
theory as
formalism that might speak to um speak
to consciousness research
so it's a it's a great question um
the normal answer from people in my
world
um would start off by saying that
consciousness is probably a vague notion
and i mean vague in a philosophical
sense that you know
at what point does a collection of
sand um grains become a pile of sand
so it admits the possibility that a
thing
may not be conscious yes it certainly
would by definition have to have a
markov blanket
you know in our formalism um but that
does not mean
it is conscious it will be
self-evidencing in the sense of
having gradient flows that um try to
minimize
self-information but that's as far as it
goes so then you ask yourself
well what kind of systems first of all
look as if they are living and then
as we move through this vague landscape
or
vague dimension towards very
sophisticated
um uh you know particles like like
yourself and myself
and what would take us from living
to um systems that had a you know a
minimal
selfhood and then even further what
would take us to systems like
philosophers
so to puzzle over the fact that they
have minimal selfhood and
i think the answer lies really in the
generative model
so if you remember um we were talking
about a genitive model as being a
probabilistic specification of causes
and consequences
that underwrites the free energy or
specifically the free energy gradients
that provide an explanation for our
dynamics so it all boils down to the
genetic model
so first of all what would it mean to be
alive
um and you know we have discussed this
in terms of just moving to you know to
have an itinerancy
to actually act upon the world so you
you need to see a particle moving around
and it would look as if it was moving
around in the service
of um sampling evidence for its own
existence
uh and maintaining itself in um you know
in this in these characteristic ranges
showing some generalized homeostasis you
know of the sort you might expect um
a worm or a single celled
system um some kinds of behavior a
single cell system might show
is that does that have any sense of self
or any sense of consciousness probably
not
and then so you then take it up to say
insects and
and and you know and small mammals and
at some point
um in this vague continuum um
you you come across the next milestone
or marker on the way
which is the kind of generative moral
that would uh
explain the consequences of action so
put it very very simply though there are
some creatures that
are systems at least that will respond
reflexively
like say microbes and uh indeed
thermostats
that will respond in a way that seems to
keep themselves within a particular
range
but crucially they don't plan
so what would it mean in terms of
planning in a deliberate work
deliberative way basically selecting
among a number of ways forward a number
of courses of action
that will lead you to
reduce uncertainty minimize your free
energy or minimize your expected
surprise
as a consequence of that action well you
would require a genetic model
of what would happen if i did that now
because what would happen is in the
future
that's a very sophisticated genitive
model so now you're actually
equipping this charity model with a
temporal depth it can reach into the
future
and if a creature or a system is endowed
with a deep genitive model that
encompasses the consequences of action
it's now in a position to choose those
actions
that it thinks will either resolve
uncertainty or
supply the most evidence for its own
existence or
put more simply um invince the
characteristic
sensory states that define it and define
uh what it is
um so then we're moving on now to
creatures that plan um and if creatures
that
plan and now have an extra bit to their
generative models
which recognize that they are planning
that have this hypothesis that
hang on um it may be the simplest
explanation
for all these multimodal
sensations is that i am a thing
and that i it is me that is um
prosecuting these reflexes or moving or
it is me that is looking
over there and now you've got a very
sophisticated generative model where you
can certainly
um imagine that there is a minimal
representation of self like self
modeling
so now we're moving closer to um the
notion
of uh conscious artifacts would they be
fully conscious would they
would they have qualitative experiences
would they have qualia um
and then the next argument is what would
license
um qualitative experience you know see
you know
what it would be like to see um red
or any other attribute of the censorium
that usually
the argument then is well that's um that
would require
the kind of genetic model that was able
to
essentially infer on its own inference
that would be able to
enact a kind of mental or covert action
in order to select in
the model itself in the message passing
in the brain for example
be able to select certain um sources of
information in the service of this
hierarchical self-evidence where
from the hierarchy like layers of of an
onion and the deeper you get into the
onion
the higher you are in this hierarchy
with the you know
recurrent message passing between each
of the layers but
if the if the deeper the core of the
onion
was now able to act upon the
intermediate
layers or levels of this hierarchical
construct
then you might now suppose that this is
a kind of mental action
that licenses you to say now this is an
agent
it's an agent that plans because it's
acting um
psychologically this would be
effectively attention
so if you can plan what to attend to
or generate
attentional selection of the
um the way that you go and secure
evidence from your world
then you might now start to develop
um a theory of what it is like to
actively perceive something um you know
i could go on at length and
probably not very usefully in terms of
how you might cast that in terms
of phenomenal transparency and opacity
in brief what was saying is that there
are certain generative models there are
certain creatures
that can um render their
percepts experienced by rendering them
opaque by acting upon them by having
this capacity of attentional selection
so now you've got to some a very
sophisticated generative model
that not only has temporal depth that
enables the
agent to plan it's also truly an
agent that may be self-aware or at least
aware of what it is
um uh it is perceiving because it can
now act upon
um the the the perception the perceptual
inference that's implicit in the
self-evidencing
but we still haven't got to
self-awareness here so
these things might be apt to describe um
um say mice um
but we don't know whether mice are
self-aware they could
you know probably they can attend to
this or that and then
you know under this if you like spectrum
of
vague vague levels of different
different kinds of consciousness
um you know they could be said to be
conscious in the sense
that they are sentient and have
qualitative experiences
but are they self-aware and if you want
to be self-aware you've now got to by
definition have
um part of your genetic model literally
part of your brain
that stands in and represents selfhood
so
just then we come back to this notion
that your
highest forms of um of
life on earth would would probably
have realized and learned
and infer that they are entities
they are agents and that becomes me and
it's me that's doing this
overt action and this covert action this
attentional
selection and then the final step would
be to go from this highest form of life
to become a philosopher when you start
to have mental models
of how it is that some people are
self-aware
and someone added for an item in terms
of the numbers is there an ed infinitum
what's the next step
after philosophy yeah as soon as i said
that i realized that i was stupid and
you'd stop me yeah no it's not okay
i think i think probably we've probably
got as far as we can
in terms of levels of recursion and i
say that because
there's a lovely um notion which i'm
sure you're aware of
this is a notion of the meta hard
problem um
no i never heard of that i should know
you'll love this
i i think it's something that was
introduced um
just in a presentation or taught by andy
clark in about 2001
and then seriously um taken up by david
chalmers
uh you know about two to three years ago
in 2018
so this is this is not the hard problem
of
um finding an explanation
for sentience uh you know what is it
like to perceive
red um it's
more why do we find why do we find
ourselves puzzling over it why do we
think it's such a it's interesting
yeah so this is not the hard problem but
what sits next to the heart problem
which is
why is it that we find it so perplexing
and difficult to explain
why is the heart problem a problem for
us um
and um you know
that that's you know to my mind it's
it's an extra level that you were
talking about so
you know now now we're asking we're
trying to explain the emergence of
philosophers
so without them to the next level
and it's a very very interesting problem
um
and it tells you immediately a number of
a number of very interesting things that
you know if i am puzzled about the fact
that i
am seeing red or that i can see red that
tells you immediately that your
generative model
has to have a model of a counter factual
where i can see red but not experience
it now that's quite remarkable
yeah to actually have that kind of
genitive model where you can imagine
yourself
you're in a structured in a very very
different way
so i use the word counterfactual there
so deliberately because you know it may
be just because we
are systems artifacts sentient artifacts
that have these very very deep genitive
models that entertain
counterfactuals and neil seth calls his
counterfactual depth
now allows us oh i spoke to neil seth
for this program he's a great guy
well i i hope he mentioned
counterfactual depth and he'd if he
doesn't he'll have to get him back and
yeah yeah no i don't think he did or
maybe i slipped up and don't remember
okay sorry yeah so the you know
this notion of counterfactual depth you
know i think is is very important
i mean it's absolutely requisite for
planning
in the sense that you know planning is
choosing the right course of action
which means you've got a series of
options all of which have these counter
factual outcomes um but of course if
you've given that model
you're given that kind of model you're
now in a position
to hypothesize counter factuals that
could never occur
such as seeing red without seeing red uh
such as um you know seeing but looking
but not seeing for example such as the
the other thought experiments that
philosophers like like you know uh
philosophical zombies
um yeah the very fact that there is
this meme of a philosophical zombie
tells you immediately that we are in
discourse
with creatures namely philosophers that
have the capacity
to um um represent
in their genitive models impossible
scenarios and counterfactuals
of the kind that you would have to uh
bring to the table
to you know to to conceive of a
of a philosophical zombie so just
perhaps even put even more simply the
fact that people can do these kinds of
thought experiments tells you a lot
about
the kinds of genetic models they use to
explain their world
and that is possibly a sufficient
explanation for the meta hard problem
uh just because we can
uh-huh okay i'm going to need to think
about that there's this lady named
annika harris
who's sam harris's wife and she has a
book on consciousness i believe it's
just called consciousness
and no offense to annika harris but the
book was
the book the best part of the book to me
was when she was talking about
philosophical zombies
that is for the people who aren't
listening how
can there be robots that look like us
that aren't conscious
and it produces an equivalent world and
she said
she said something so interesting which
is that the fact that we're talking
about
consciousness implies that we're
conscious is because in an equivalent
zombie-like world
it's hard to imagine why they would come
up with that question
so that's what separates us from them
yeah
that sounds exactly and that that sounds
exactly like how andy clark would phrase
it you know the big thing is
why are we so puzzled about
consciousness and sentience
so that sounds very very close to to
you know the core question that
underwrites the the meta heart problem
or the meta problem
yeah anna lukomsky asks she says that's
lovely to hear when i told her that i
was
speaking to you she's fantastic news
about carl fristen i'm
curious to know if he's an idealist or a
physicalist
now i'm biased towards idealism i'm
speaking in terms of her
she's a psychiatrist by the way or a
psychologist and she says
well first of all are you an idealist or
a physicalist
um i i'm very happy to bat for both
sides depending on
who who i'm talking to so okay so you're
uncommitted right now
um no no i mean i i'm happy to commit to
either so
you're i see this through the lens of
the people i know in philosophy so
on the one hand my friend andy clark um
would would be um
somebody who believes you know certainly
would not
um adopt a a radical
idealist whereas
would celebrate the markov blanket that
separates you
from the external world and therefore
the external world can never be known
um it's only ever accessed vicariously
by the markov blanket
and he might he might then um take a
more skeptical uh position
um you know i think that the maths of
the free energy principle
um really forces you to to um
um uh two back for both sides on the one
hand it is absolutely true
that our making sense of the world
through the sensory veil
supplied by the markov blanket precludes
any anything out there that will be ever
known
um that is certainly true so it's only
consistent with brain and of that like
thought experiments there
there will be no way um that you could
verify or not
what's actually going on out there
everything is this sort of delusion or
hallucination
that is entrained and grounded by
sensory evidence but
you know you know you never know the
causes of that sensory evidence that's
the whole premise of imprints you know
active imprints encapsulating
or the um encapsulating
the take on self-organization as a
process of inference
so that's that that would be sort of you
know the you know one side of the
defense
the problem is that when you um if you
commit to that
it's very difficult to actually simulate
um
or engineer sentience because in order
to do that you've actually got to
generate the sensations
um the sensory states of the markov
blanket on uh
that the the agent can infer and of
course when i talk about
or refer to the good regulator theorem
um i'm implicitly assuming that there is
a world out there to be regulated
i am assuming that you know the quality
of a generative model
as measured by its free energy um
is in relation to what is being modeled
so i have to commit
to some realism uh in the sense that i'm
saying there is a model
so it's very difficult for me to answer
that because on the one hand
um is if it's a model of something then
the something must be real
on the other hand it's always the on the
process of inference under a particular
model
means i'll never know whether there's
anything real or not so
you know it it it sort of accommodates
both points of view
and resolves neither i guess so
the psychological reason you're saying
sorry there's not a psychological reason
that you're saying
you're both a physicalist and a realist
or
neither it's it's not because you don't
want to offend anyone
it's actually because your your model
accounts for both
well one is like ontological the other
is epistemic so one is like we can't
have knowledge of it but the other one
but at the same time you're assuming
that there exists a world that's
independent
yes and that's a beautiful way of
putting it but but also i also don't
want to offend anybody as well but yes
you're a lovely chap you want to keep
your charming nature okay
so this person named matthew nahemi says
does
referring to you does carl fristen know
alfred korczymski
and what does he think about his
theories
that deserve a vague bell but you're
going to have to um tell me
then forget it because i actually don't
know this person and i have been told
that i need to learn more about this
person
dr jt velikovsky of the university of
newcastle from austra
australia who has published some work on
holland part-time theory structure of
the meme
some memes like richard dawkins memes he
asks
do you expect like david boehm suggested
that the scale size of entities in the
universe
eg matter energy go infinitely smaller
eg smaller beyond quarks and also
infinitely larger
eg to multiple universes um
yes i mean i think that would be that
would be a sort of mathematical take
um on um the application
if we wanted to do that of of the the
apparatus of the renormalization group
when trying to understand
um the separation of temporal scales
between
different levels of organization which
is an important part
of the free energy formalism when it
comes to thinking about
markov blankets and mark off blankets
say you know organs that comprise
cells where each cell comprises
organelles
that themselves comprise molecules that
themselves comprise out
and so on and so forth and then the
other way organs constituting phenotypes
phenotypes
cons constituting populations across
specifics constituting in groups and out
groups constituting species and
and so on right up to um sort of a
cosmological
scale so you know i think mathematically
um that that's a very comfortable
position to adopt
um so that you know there is no lower
upper bound on the application of the
renormalization
or the apparatus of the renormalization
group when you move from one scale to
the next
um which you can do very gracefully when
it comes to
certainly modeling for example um
applying the free energy principle to
single cells in a network of neurons
and then core straining that to try
to model um you know parts of the brain
as self-evidencing through
you know physical motion through to
course training that and then trying to
model
um populations talking to each other or
interacting through them uh the markov
blankets that defines
an organization or a family or a set of
con specifics
defines it in relation to say the uh the
environment or the econish so these are
just examples
of um lifting exactly the same dynamics
the gradient flows uh that underwrite
the free energy principle
from one scale to the next and in so
doing
working out what the states are what the
you know when you say the states of
affairs
or the sensory states or the internal
states yeah what are they
and um when you sort of drill down on
that
what you can do is use the um the
renormalization group formalism um
to be moving from one scale to the next
you basically take um mixtures of
blanket states
uh and then those mixtures of blanket
states
technically the eigenfunctions of the
blanket states now become the states of
the next level and then
you look at the conditional dependencies
of the states the next level then you
find the markov blanket then you take
the eigen
functions of those states and then they
become states in the next level
at each level of course graining you get
bigger
and slower so before we were talking
about
sort of this from quantum to classical
um um that inherits simply from
this um successive course graining but
at each point exactly the same
free energy um um
for like lagrangian you know the way
that you would write down
the dynamics and you know on one region
the energetics
this functional forms are exactly
preserved you're just
swapping out sort of um your microscopic
states um for mixtures of microscopic
states in particular repeat the eigen
functions or mixtures
of blanket states to get to the next
level noting that
the black you're throwing away the
internal states remember the internal
states
um are independent of the external
states
given the markov blanket and vice versa
which means there's nothing in the
internal states or any particular
particle
that is not if you like um encoded
in the blanket states if you wanted to
move to the next level
so each level you're throwing away the
internal states
um that can have very fast dynamics and
you're picking out
the slower fluctuations of them on the
markov blanket
on the blanket states themselves so the
states at the next level up
now fluctuate much much more slowly and
they encompass
they have a larger spatial scale as well
so
um you know once one has that um
that that sort of um recursive um
you know not proof by induction but the
same spirit as a proof by induction
where you move from
from one level to the next level uh that
once one has that apparatus in play
there is no need to ask when does when
does the process stop or where did it
begin
um and in a sense you dissolve those
questions because you're only interested
in one particular scale and how it
relates to scale above
and the scale below i mean you can go um
if you're if you like um astronomy
uh or you know um you're interested in
the physics
of the cosmos then you know you'll be
going i'd say six
scales uh you know towards towards
classical mechanics
if you're interested in string theory
and
uh small particle accelerators then
you'd be going to say six scales down to
very very small things
you know towards the quantum level um
but we is six just a number
for an example or are you specifying
something in particular um
well yeah yeah it is a number i pulled
out of the hat but
but it's probably about that when one
looks at um
when one looks at
the time constants empirically
associated with any particular scale or
any set of markov blanks at different
scales
and then one goes to the next scale
using
you know this is not this is not um
magic
it has been applied for example to brain
imaging time series where you
you look at every um little cubic
patch of the brains see a few
millimeters in size
and then you say well that's the scale
i'm going to start with and i'll take
the
eigenmodes or the eigenfunctions um
literally as the activity of each of
this little chunk of brain
and then i've got say thousands of
states and then i'll look at the
dependencies and i'll work out a markov
blanket and it could be
a markov blanket around a little chunk
of brain the size of your thumbnail
and then you can take the eigen
functions
of the markov blanket of that little
chunk of brain
um and then you put the chunks together
and you find the markov blanket at that
level and then you talk about lobes of
the brain
and then you talk about the entire brain
and then you think about well lots of
brains together
at a scientific conference there's so
many
whatever almost every four sentences
that you
speak three ideas occurred to me and i
just
want to explore them all so here's an
example we're not going to explore them
i'll just say them
when you mention that the internal
states are independent of the external
vice versa that means there's almost an
arbitrariness as to which one you call
internal
and which means that you can at least
i'm surmising i'm gonna
i'm pretty much asking but either way
then that means that you can
imagine the environment models you in a
sense and then i wondered
well what's the connection between that
and the holographic principle in string
theory
which says that at the boundary it
encodes the information
anyway okay that's just what occurs to
me and also multiple
dissociative personality disorder i also
want to know about that
but it's not about me joanna dong has a
question
she says my question to carl fristed how
do you explain the meaning of life using
the free energy principle that's the
easy question you can answer that in
like 10 seconds
um i've never been asked that before the
meaning of life
so no i just got to use my favorite
words tautology and deflation
um you know the meaning is in the
existence
um the shape of that existence defines
the goals for um the
existential imperatives to keep yourself
in the in those existential domains so
it's just in the existence it's just the
shape
of things that exist that define their
own meaning
and you know in a sense um you could
look at self-evidencing as finding
meaning
uh for your life or your
fi finding um or understanding
the um
the model for which you're trying
to accrue evidence um
and what that basically means is if
you're reading that
as a um as a psychiatrist or a
philosopher
you're basically trying to understand
yourself and your own
genitive models so if you understand
your own purpose
for your purpose is just to aspire to
this these attracting
sets um that define you as the kind of
thing you are
and then the meaning would i think rest
upon this
some kind of self moral where now you
recognize you you're this kind of person
so you you can spin it off at a number
of different levels
so it wasn't a very i'll think of a more
succinct access to yeah
psychologically and attracting set would
be what mathematically that's fine but
for someone who is just interested in
how one lives their life
is this just a recapitulation of know
thyself
yes or the thing the things that the the
things that um
you are attracted to literally the
things that you see yourself being
attracted to the things that you see
yourself aspiring and working towards
um so what do you find interesting and
admirable
is that what you mean yeah yeah yeah
that was that at a very high level
but remember you know this operates at
all scales
of of a deep charging model where
remember the core
is dealing with with sort of more
abstract things such as
you know being likable being loved being
rich
but at the periphery you know there are
still um
there's a model of basically body
temperature body
um not being in pain so these are also
things that make me happy
in a sense you know these are the these
are attracting states
it's attractive to be at a particular
temperature attractive not
to sense pain it's attractive um you
know
to be hydrated to a particular extent uh
at some level it is also attractive you
know
if you have very deep genitive models
um that have this counter factual depth
then there are certain
counter factual outcomes that you would
find very surprising will be
unattractive
and there'll be other outcomes which you
would have learned
this is the kind of outcome that i
aspire to this is the kind of gender
model i
am you know at that point that i think
it would be
quite fair um to start thinking about
this in terms of you know
i'm going to develop this reputation you
know if i if i
say this or if i donate this or
i'm going to um i'm going to be this
kind of
uh person uh if i take these actions
so there are certainly entailed in the
prior
beliefs that constitute the genetic
model ways of behaving ways of being
outcomes that you a priori expect to
happen
and generally these are going to be
things that are consistent with your
self-image with the with with your
self-model and interestingly also
require
um an optimism bias to sort of you know
because of this self-fulfilling prophecy
of all our actions and decisions and
choices and behavior
if they're all in the service of
realizing
our fantasy about the kind of thing that
we are
then we are always behaving and
selecting those information and
ignoring other kinds of information um
in order to find evidence indeed this is
the kind of thing i am so i'm going to
ignore any evidence
that run runs counter to my self-image
you know that i'm not liked or not
believed or that i'm very poor or
very hungry unless i can do something
about it
um so so you know
that's a real i think it's a really
interesting question because
it speaks to the um both the
self-fulfilling prophecy
but and this sort of optimism
optimistic aspect of active inference
which is not a fallacy
it is it is absolutely essential in
keeping us
on track and keeping it as within these
attracted
attracting or attractive states
so if you were doing if you're a
behavioral psychologist this would just
be
um some kind of reward if you're a
control engineer it would be some kind
of negative loss function
so you just score being in a given state
in terms of the probability that you
would find me
in that state and if it is unattractive
and the kind of thing i would avoid
that simply is a statement that has a
very low probability
that means that the negative logarithm
is very very high it just means it's
surprising
so it's just another way of saying that
the attracting
set of states or the attractive states
are those that i am not surprised
to be in that they are comfortable
they're familiar
given i am who i am this is exactly the
kind of state that i think i should
i should pause and be occupied
again almost all that you say there's so
many thoughts that occur
i'll say some of them now not for you to
explore but maybe for people in the
comments section to explore
i was thinking when you were talking
about different goals that one has and
there's different levels of abstraction
so
one is to regulate your body temperature
at an extremely low level then at a high
level one might be to
be a lovable person or to love someone
else then i was wondering well though
you can go much much lower to parts that
you don't have control over so
it's it's you want to have
transcriptase in your cells so that you
can have
a replication of dna but you also want
to have cell walls it's not like you can
control that but that's at the extremely
low level
and then at a high level what i'm
wondering is is there a relationship
between the highest ideal and then god
and then is there a relationship to
being fragmented there and having
what's not monotheistic so that is
polytheistic
and then if you have what's polytheistic
and there's a contradiction between them
is that one of the reasons why in
monotheism they say you cannot serve two
gods
and is that related to people who are
well all of us are in some degree
psychologically
not fully integrated but is there a
relationship between monotheism and
being fully integrated as a person where
you have one
goal that you're working toward and
they're not contradicted
at some higher step so you're living in
a in a more congruent fashion
you don't have to comment on that you
could probably say that's all
foolishness but
people oh no no no don't do i can't
resist because when you say i have lots
of thoughts as well
um so that that sort of can we act in
order to make sure that our messenger
rna is working properly
um yes you can actually but you'd have
to use this sort of um
sort of scale different scales of markov
blankets
uh but also there's there is actually
a formalism that allows you to um
look at the way that say the central
nervous system
through neuroendocrinology and through
sort of your
neuro immunological mechanisms does
actually
have an express effect on on gene
expression and
right so this speaks to the sort of the
you know the
the transactions both between markov
blankets but also
if a markov blanket at one scale exists
that necessarily implies existence at
another scale
so a cell can only exist if the organ
exists but in the same
spirit and in in reverse the organelle
exists in virtue of the cells existing
and all of this has to maintain
a free energy minimizing dynamic in
order to keep uh
you know both scales in play at the same
time so you know it's a really
i think that's a really interesting
example the god versus
um or monit uh polytheistic versus
monitors
monotheistic models of the world i think
that
that's that's you know a lovely
description of
um um sort of you know sources of
cognitive dissonance but possibly of a
theological or existential
um or the sort that might underwrite or
not ontological security
that you know if i do have these
counterfactuals
about different things of the kind of
person that i
am or the um the date is that
i commit or subscribe to um then that's
just
another example of the opportunity to
resolve uncertainty but
in that sense there's also uncertainty
there there's this puzzlement that
underwrites
the meta heart problem that is it this
kind of god of that kind of god is it
the
holy father or or the holy son
um and
into g by introducing that uncertainty
you do
you may well um expose yourself to
culture dissonance
and ambiguity and an existential angst
out that level
which you will actually try to resolve
so that's this again this
imperative for self-evidencing is acting
in a way to minimize expected surprise
or uncertainty in the future so it may
well be that certain
um clerics
certain sorry what clerics uh clerics
clerics yes or people people people
you know with an ecclesiastical
uh um leaning they may spend a lot of
time trying to resolve
that kind of uncertainty that kind of
come to distance yeah
okay two quick questions that's it faraz
says in the context of embody cognition
and by the way faraz is someone
who graduated from u of t
right around here in neuroscience and i
forgot the other one so he's going to
comment in the comment section about
what i forgot in the context of embody
cognition what is the relationship
between perception and mathematics
and furthermore if the external world
perceives
our actions can we extrapolate from that
assertion
the idea that our actions matter to the
world as well
so that um that question you you sort of
hinted at
before when you were when you were um
the duality between internal external
exactly yeah that that sort of um
perfect symmetry
um which i thought was you know that
that was insightful and i think
um that insight sort of speaks to the
second half half of this question here
um so you know it is certainly the case
that
when you uh simulate um agents
con specifics in a particular
environment or eco niche
um and you just integrate these
uh simulation of physics engines um
using um uh the free energy principle
you get the um the kind of
um learning that um you would normally
expect to see
in the agents about the environment but
that is exactly mirrored
by the environment learning about the
denizens that you know it plays host to
so i'm sure you know this but you know
my favorite example from colleagues who
really you know push these arguments as
far as they
they can go at the present time uh my
favorite um
their favorite and my favorite example
is a notion of a
desire path or an elephant path which is
the
the phenomenon that say
i'm going to get my coffee from the cafe
on the other side of a green or a park
and i can either walk around on the
pavement or i can take a shortcut
across the grass and if i so do
um i will eventually me and all my con
specifics will eventually
wear a a dusty trail
uh of grassless signs and queues
uh from uh you know my office directly
to the cafe
so from the point of view of the
environment this is basically the
environment learning about the behavior
of the kinds of agents that you know
that occupies that that
that environment so the environment is
learning about the behavior
by being eroded by being changed so it's
literally just
remembering in its structure in its
subpersonal
structure it is learning about the uh
the con specifics
that are good for occupying that
environment
the con specifics that are occupying
that environment what are the con
specifics
oh a con a con specific um you and i are
con specifics because we're
from the same species so is it sorry
it's just a way of describing
an ensemble of or a collection of
phenotypes
agents that have the you know come from
the same species
um and the environment can learn this is
the kind of phenotype
that operates well in my environment
whilst at the same time the phenotypes
are trying to change to operate better
in this environment so there's
a there's a your circular causality
your while while the while the the
the phenotypes or the con specifics are
trying to adapt to the environment
the environment is also adapting to
those con specifics so it's a dance
um that in fact can get quite high order
in the sense now that that you and i
will now see the path and realize oh
that must
this path leads to to somewhere that it
must be nice for things like me to go
so i can just infer seeing a desire path
that it will lead to something i desire
because i know
that everybody else who has used that
are con specifics
they like the same kinds of things they
have the same attracting sets
so now the environment has learned about
the the phenotypes and has
memorized it in its structure and now
the phenotypes are now using that to
infer the kinds of things that i should
do
so now you get something like just using
the environment
to cooperate and to signal and to change
um and to provide information for other
things other creatures like me
and you can take that right through to
the emergence of roads
of traffic lights of language so you
move these arguments that's interesting
cultural domain um and now you've you
know
so language is that part of the
environment or is it part of papa's
third world or
is it you know is it part of your brain
i i yeah i don't think you tie it down
like that because of this circular
causality
um that you you hinted at more than
hinted at
when you're when you recognize that a
markov blanket
you know it's quite arbitrary what is
internal external just depends upon
which point of view you're taking so
there's a really interesting question
which you can take in many many
different directions
you know i i i'm personally not
um not taking it in those directions
because i got distracted by other things
but i have lots of young colleagues
around the world who are really trying
to
try to understand this relationship to
evolutionary psychology
evo devo uh the relationship to niche
construction
and the relationship to what andy clark
would have would have
promoted which is the designed
environment so one of the
one of the sort of um you know p
parts of the triple uh you know the four
e's
you know so yes it is embodied but
there's also
um you know an extension it's situated
um so the environment not just the
physical environment
outside my body but my body as
environment as well starts to become
you know an important part of this
reciprocal loop and this sort of
joint free energy minimizing mechanics
that rests upon a reciprocal exchange
between
you know one side of a markov blanket
and the other side of the markov blanket
i'll just close with with the first part
of the question which is
does that mean the environment perceives
i i would say possibly not um
it certainly would be the case
mathematically speaking that the
environment is
learning but we generally reserve the
notion of perception to refer to
to perceptual inference or inference
about states
of the world as opposed to the
parameters of a generative model
which um are more attributes of
contingencies
laws and the like so that we we infer
that the world is in this state or that
state at this point in time
but we learn the contingencies and the
lawful mappings the likelihoods
and the transition probabilities um that
underwrite
the changes and transitions in the state
the other flux of states in the world
so um it it's it's probably the case
that the environment
the physical environment not the body
environment but so you know things like
roads and paths and buildings
trees um
they learn that they probably don't
infer and perceive in the sense of
having qualitative experience of qualia
but they do learn
um you know they do update their
parameters in a way
to model what's on the other side of
their mark off blanket which is you and
me
thank you sir you've given you've been
far too generous with your time
and i appreciate it immensely i think
this conversation will be
fruitful for quite a few people
especially more on the
philosophical end there's not many most
of the interviews with you are more
technical so
i'm glad that we got a bit philosophical
even though i love some of the technical
questions
i have maybe the 30 30 more that i
didn't get to but
we'll save that for the next time well
as as last time it's been a real
pleasure talking to you
thank you i look forward to our next uh
next exchange
thank you man appreciate it honestly i
do thank you so much and you've helped
me psychologically as well because
well just you telling me that other
people are
are going through what i'm going through
but sometimes even worse and sometimes
better but it's normal
that gave me at first some anxiety
because i was thinking well
if your colleagues are going through
psychotic breaks i'm not at a psychotic
break but that means that it's possible
and if cantor studying infinity could go
through
psychotic breaks i wonder how much of
what i'm doing is self-imposed from
my own study of consciousness and
investigating the universe
so it gives me a bit of anxiety because
it's like okay well this is a path that
may lead to that
but at the same time it gives me some
calm because you're saying
it's okay first of all if it gets
serious it can be treated
don't worry about that and and it
doesn't seem like i give off any signs
of
being schizophrenic even though i'm
concerned about it so
yes you're concerned means you can't be
you can't be psychotic i i did cross my
mind when you're talking about the
monotheism versus polytheism um and
resolving that sort of cognitive
dissonance and that existential angst
you get when you you know you could be
this way or that way
i mean the very ability to entertain
these counterfactuals
is very very close to to to psychosis
and sorry
um you know the kind of the kind of
angst you see manic depressive psychosis
so it's a natural state for curious
creatures
so the anxiety you're gonna go over the
edge is just a price you pay for being a
curious creature
um and as you say you'll know when
you're going too far
and you either get your wife to call him
the doctor or
you'll just sort of commit to one way of
being on another way of being
um you know you you you will know that
but it's
you know what i'm saying is don't
you shouldn't be frightened of this you
should you should celebrate this
you know which is why i always encourage
you to make sure you write down
everything you trust me i write down
of ontological security what i don't do
is rewrite and that's my problem
as well because plenty of the writing is
in the rewriting
and retaining it is in the rewriting as
well
but anyway i got to work on that thank
you sir
you're i gotta i feel like i've gotten
along with you
more than almost anyone that i've
interviewed and i've interviewed almost
50 or
50 plus people so i don't i don't know
what to attribute to that but
it's probably your your demeanor and
your
there's a caringness that comes across
in your voice and i appreciate that and
humbleness as well thank you
all right sounds very grace of you thank
you very much
you